The report that I was given, that I did was,
I filtered for that, just the place again,
and then I filtered for guests.
It was that plate size, which was the 8th inch,
and then when I created the report, what we do is we put them
in our, like, job orders. So instead of,
instead of putting it in the job order for that other job number,
I put it in the job for this one that I want to release.
So, it'll have all the of that information on there.
And it's funny because, like, as soon as that message popped up,
I called him and I was like, I don't want it included on this
cutter because I want it to make my own cutter,
but now knowing I can't make a cutter until it's cut,
well, I'm not going to go back in after I've released this job to
try and cut and make a cutter, because I can't release the job until
Problem is,
it's all backdrop Well,
there were some topics where I could literally do my homework without that argument.
What I think that is.
Thank you much for bringing it up. You'll be able Thank you.
Who's thinking of you somewhere?
And you would think,
like, at least let me create the cutter.
And redline
it And make this cutter not active until you're done with this thing.
You need something
Well, it realistically should have the PO in the job that it's pulling
it from anyways, and then eventually, the key number.
So, like, it has all the information to pull it in from.
Like, it's the simple fact that you,
can't create it until it's cut.
That's where I draw, like, uhm,
it just doesn't I mean,
I don't know if it exists at all,
it doesn't exist here, but if at all,
I don't know where it is. But if it'll allow me to put those
parts on that plate before it's cut,
you know it's gonna have a REM for it,
so, like, what? You know?
That's their problem. That's their problem. It's not their issue.
Don't think I would want their issue. Blimey, they've got it there.
This is not with pointless action.
We've got to do it. Well, what if the opposite You're going to the
only one who's going to start breaking all this respect. I know.
We're going to have a problem. But, in terms of,
All these sites have been elucidated.
What do you want me to do?
Start a family, but... Alright,
Follow back. Yeah,
I just gotta go reprogram it so that I just throw it all I
need some, uh, some water. I'm keep my Please
tell me some of the other giants. All of us.
I was looking at all the stuff that, uh, so I'm going to,
because I didn't have sales for it, to the estimate folder.
Yeah. And I just started going backwards in time to see what was in
the estimate folder. Yeah. It was really embarrassing.
I'm only looking at the folder,
that's the second one. I wasn't looking at all the ones that we were,
and did, so, That's the only one.
Very good. Because I recognize those drawings.
Yeah, Scratch my head,
but I assume they're kind of gearing up the reason they
want to hire people like you, me, and this other group.
God, if it's doing the uhm,
scheduling, they must be ramping up to do a lot of little big stuff.
That's the message. I think,
if you are, they will come chanepin.
I don't think they're at that stage yet,
cause like I said, they're gonna- I'm gonna go like 10 to the quarter,
get out of enough to give the person Jira a plan for how I
was gonna tackle it, the match. That's what I'm Yeah.
I want to push some easy shit here,
right? I want to talk to a guy about N20 saws there,
and we'll just- . . . It doesn't even- .
. You know, he's doing everything on any of the tape measure.
That saw it, or cake,
because we haven't- . . I gotta- Yeah,
so I figure- He knows what it's like.
You can upload the standoff as a case.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah, it was the proper LED.
So, he can- There are more in the machines,
too, right? So I don't want to make one of those.
And I'm supposedly uploading this. I'm like,
actually, yeah, but it's all bad. Alright, get all the things that are going
to happen now. Yeah. With the machine,
it has to be good. Absolutely. It's good to go.
We had that exact same song. So, Yeah, we got the AC-DC out there
coming on. Assuming these guys program,
you know, they want to do something to see.
I mean, for this facility in M20,
it's a small saw. Yeah. We were using M40 of us,
and we were instructional. First of all, we're reviewing it to have all kinds
of stuff, but I really don't think they do.
That's a big stretch over here. I think it's fun.
It's fun. That's what it appears to be.
Oh, I think I'll be glad to give you some seminal questions.
I'm not sure, but that's one of the things. Thanks.
What is your report?
You're going to do it before you fly, interesting.
Ah, it'll probably be something next week, so we're going to do that.
begin So, what happens is on there playing right back on people
always. Cause I know my voice wants to deal here, Jeff wants to deal
with me. I'll see you rather than come from you,
and I said, hey, let's have the,
uh, cuz Chris put one out already, and I told him.
Tom? Tom? I you, but Chris already put one out.
No, no, no, no, saying it. Yeah, I know we'll be getting plenty of
requests if we have a good amount of history game here,
so I'll tell you a I hear
the room is about following it. I leave it in a second. I don't
hear it. It's good. I'm coming. Very good.
. . Hang on. Hey, I was planning to show up yesterday morning for
a cave. I here, I was talking to a couple people,
and I mean And go on look. This guy mics.
Yeah, he's making a program.
He doesn't say anything. It's great. Well,
yeah. . I mean, he's like, yeah.
You've been here all week. Yeah, you're here for the most support for him.
Yeah. I feel like he's the other friend that's been doing.
Yeah. Yeah.
He's pretty much right. Yeah. So you have this guy in front of you.
I think you'll just say, hey, can this do that?
That's what we're looking for. There Ready? And, uh,
uh, yeah. Thanks, Mavana. I would really like to see some bit again.
It's just right now. . I think we've got to consolidate,
get it to start all engines and tech on the lead.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Just a Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. You just want some water out of it. Ah,
there's 33 broken.
Instead of walking, we'll walk or to see that as well.
You can't. We'll run down. We'll just,
we'll get to the end of the video. . . . I don't think
it's 33, because I've been trying to ride it down, but I think it's
10. Yeah. Yeah. That's,
that's what we're tasting. Yeah. I think we're about to.
Yeah. I keep here and I'm good at the tech over there.
I think they're communicating, using tech. And that's a nice one.
I think that- I don't know if these others- I don't know if they're
in the shop exactly to you yet, or what they're using.
Yeah. I don't know if they're using tech or something like that.
Yeah, and I think that, uhm,
it's the really good thing with me is that it shouldn't come to me.
With Travis, Eric, and for anybody who needs to be- Good.
Yeah, quick. To Jessica,
I think we're going to get two other people here, okay?
Thank you. Listen to the shot,
baby. I would have to go find a baby for a lot of money
in the guy that I know about. Three bucks when you're doing this,
yeah? There's a guy who wants to do the shoot. Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you. Bye. Thank you much. He's over there.
Exactly the same. He goes to everything in and
out of here. You And I used to,
you said, well, I was there. Okay, show me how to do this.
Uh, what? You need to come back.
Take that, but I like this. Yes. Yes. Yes,
I like this. It's like that. It's hard enough,
so I'm not gonna work with the other two, but there's a name.
Okay, so was a We'll a second.
First new land, and everybody knows it's one of these.
I don't know if I'll do it again, it's out of line.
I don't wanna release some of this. I don't wanna do it again.
Good bye. I know they're not in Bitbucket, but that is in Bitbucket.
But that's what I did to if Bitbucket was in before,
because, the base setup needs to be done,
and the city needs to be made with this,
you know, tablet, what they came with, with all those things on your phone,
sure. I think it just changed the key.
That's what Chris wants, too. And what?
But when I ask you that if you don't like the campaign.
Small front jeans and sits there, can you try and play?
Yeah. I go with you, and take a look.
No, you should be better at you if you really want to hang out.
You should be to visit the latest. and one, right? Oh,
okay. Yeah, go ahead. I guess so.
So, how do you manage this? So, just stretch with everything.
Thank very much. I'm going be great for you right now. Yeah, I understand.
Yeah, I like that. So, it kills me.
And then, well, whenever I get into exploration,
I'm going to be. Oh, yeah. And I love some of the cheap stuff.
I do too. And I like the other, because they're,
they're the worst and you're at it on a company.
Love you guys. I see you. You they're the worst.
You know, they have no certain business. I'll do what you know in a
few minutes. Yeah, I have to.
The other city, the island, I'm tired of repair. Yeah. Meekin' it.
Meekin' it. Meekin' it.
Meekin' it. Meekin' it. Meekin' Meekin' it. Meekin' Meekin' it. Please sister,
let me hear it. It was really good and attractive labor.
It was really good for me because I've seen this for 20 years.
But I think that
this really constrains systems.
It takes out all of the power that the estimators have had.
Yeah. I'll see you and move them to the designers.
Mm-hmm. It's not all of a designer, they don't know the business.
They're just making drives, but until the design- So.
Mm-hmm. Nothing else could get done.
Yeah. Because the material couldn't get built.
Yeah. All that stuff would procure my guide to- Today,
EDS has to wait for designing a push to consolidate it.
Yes. And- We went from job buying for jobs
to buying the inventory. So let's say four jobs come up.
Yeah. You know, purchasing guy consolidates it all in
order to whatever. Yeah.
You have no idea. A Yeah, inventory,
hold up, hold up, hold over to review.
Boom. You just don't grab that,
whatever you want. Yeah. But I think it's a shit show for job
shops. Yeah, it'll be like, we're just seeing it,
we're just seeing it in the environment. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Let's take a look at what we're going to do
in this room.
Umm, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. He's going to
I'm going to do no time, not scratch. Oh,
you should grab it. Umm. But they're going to set up,
from here on, . Oh, okay,
that's the point. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, since we did.
Yeah. Yeah, since we didn't want to make them able to have the,
They're trying to meet all the desires and who's actually buying it.
It's easy to buy. Right, doesn't it?
I know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You But I think eventually,
I don't know what system that's gonna be. Yeah,
I think what it sounds like, the others. There is.
Don't you think I need to try the smart projects that are going on
in front of me? Yeah, I should appreciate themselves.
I don't want to tell you that. It's going to be good to hear
from these guys, and they're very simple. I'm sorry,
but that is not true. No, that's true,
man. Thanks. I'm sorry.
and six pieces of paint. And we'll do all right.
Bye. All right.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. You did that
too, but you are the worst-gated deaf-wealth.
I said everybody's fresh-eats, so here,
we're gonna buy something for you so don't- I'm gonna fill this out right
to mean what you plot. I mean,
that was- that's actually a procedure,
right? No default. I'm gonna give you a job.
I'm gonna leave it at the same time as you. So I gotta talk.
Yeah, I'm gonna tell them where to sit at. I'm Joe Schnaup.
But I'm gonna help all the way through my- I'm gonna feed them.
So they send you- I didn't mean flat-bar,
you know, I meant some of the barrels. No, I'm also- Oh,
great. This is our best option and review
it over. Okay.
So, uh, what do you think is that, uh, does do you like to?
Just you know, uh, so, uh, yeah. See you guys.
We'll you next week. So, he kind of does it.
He does a lot of it the smaller, and we're just making it look
like this. Got it. And that's gonna make it look more.
. . . . . . . You know, out even so,
there's lots of hot air. And we got,
yeah, to consumer." relative.
Teary little born with some of them, I don't know what they were saying.
See ya. No, I'm not. Alright. Bye.
So, uh, I said, my mom's going to be running out of this place,
I've been doing it for a while, and I've personally come back,
so, uh, it will be, uh, a really good entry.
That's what I'm thinking. Yeah. Yeah.
In my opinion, I've been doing it 15
years. Yeah,
I've been doing it 15 years. Yeah. In Europe, it's just these ones, these
ones, they're in their reality environment. Just like,
I'm getting shot.
I'm trying to practice this morning yesterday. I'm living there. And because,
again, so I was just opening. I love seeing if I could recover or
I could get. Well, I'm truly this week.
I haven't done a longer just set myself.
No. No. That's not what they need to donate.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We're like faith. One guy.
We're faith. I don't even need that stuff. Yeah. We're not going to get
over here. They should be. We're going to be business best.
Yeah. Okay. What's that?
One, two, three. . . One, two, three. One,
two, three. right now,
do you need to do the system? Will you first of all,
I'll be in. I'm to drop down to put in your face to chew
your license. Again, we'll, we'll set the power down.
There'll be, there'll be, we want to, uh, give it a sip.
And the Symphanie route, bottle it? Yeah, I can,
I can, I can. You can't do anything.
You can't just do everything, but you can't do anything,
edit, and add, you know, so just screw up everything.
And then just, you, oh yeah.
I haven't gotten it like, you. I say,
well, I have an ASU,
I need to move here sometimes, and I got to work out, I was
using the program for it. Okay. Alright.
Alright. It's the same, you know, the transmittals,
drawing them, and we're putting it in there.
Um, I did it for Mr. Good probably.
Love you. Yeah, but I never did any of these things,
right? No, I don't think it's doing it in the end,
but that's pretty cool, that's cool. We'll video.
Yeah, so I watch everybody and physically do it.
There is so many different types of things.
Yeah, it's gonna appear when it keeps tellin'. This is pretty good.
I tell everybody I've done that, that I'm new to this.
It's like. Thank watching. You got two sizes in this program.
You got the estimated dimensions. Easy baby baby baby.
I'm a little bit of a huge step.
you Yeah, it is. The warning is you're listening to me.
Whereas the rest of the system is not as much.
They're not their set up. They're not. You are as much as them.
It's the thing that, if you have a lot of movement to watch, something
like that. So yeah, I'm going to give today with the model and the
portrait. but it makes me happy. I haven't done that, but I haven't probably
been here that time. Well,
I actually did that for you. I still want this one,
uh, done. I'm going here, you like,
you can't bring the shop, you know, and so he used,
you know, it was pretty weird, it's all over.
That, that model to be,
It's the best tool, but it's the best thing we got,
yeah, to get it on the first screen.
Appoint key, it's not even all of that. You But,
you know, to see what's happening with that, I'll get it going.
It has a pretty little bit to see. I'll get it going,
right? Then I'll see one meeting with Ray.
I'm sorry. Yeah. So they get out of New York,
then we file a little bit. And I,
I like it, but it was super model.
But I did a bit. The, the, the, the uh,
the other thing on that one is, yeah. Eh? Eh?
I know you can go with,
eh, if I'm not singing with me. you. Alright, so the next one could
find this, and you would like to do the drives,
yeah, pull the drives into the shot, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought that was a good noise. you know,
that's cool, that's cool. That's amazing.
That's cool. That one,
uhm, bigger. you Well,
yeah, you feel like you've learned enough about another company to sit here on
and forth. Uhm, yeah, it's listening.
Oh, yeah. I agree a lot.
I didn't mean I couldn't have just been very bad about it. Sure.
Yeah, much so. I'm going go ahead and have a good time.
What do you think? Uh,
uhm, ehm, ehm, ehm, uhm,
All right. I'm excited for the third year of your three-champ
to go out and to chime in the spot like to see if you
guys can manage it. Yeah. Okay.
Let's do it. We are in now. So we'll get some of
shots. Sometime sometimes we have come back to consider that.
Yeah. Most of them. I may know.
Today we have one demo. Come on, come come on.
Go and tell them to be back. We can do that.
We'll just gotta get it. Are you having the demo?
And you'll know this, uh, show you. You remember?
Umm, yes, they were talking, you know, we went through the weekend,
and I was tired of it, and umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm,
umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm, umm,
fortnightly tablet so, umm,
I-I think that was pretty well,
umm, uhm, procedure not necessary. But it had something that you wanted to look
for, set up in here,
and then we can go through a couple of the assemblies in there.
And then mark them as complete, and we can go through that process,
see if it looks up again, if you'd like. And what we did,
can we go through most of the code, Steph? That's good. Good evening. Mr.
Early in the week, when he was estimated,
we'd tail for him in the code as production. So, um,
on the codeings, we have, situations where,
depending on the size of the material,
it will go 30 to 3 wheel over there and go take half a
buck. . those are different styles right,
so umm. Anyone know here.
All right. So finally,
we need you to have to go in and try to set the car
up and have some food. So that's- I don't know what
type of material, uhm, but is there a, like, a tag, too, so that
the third behavior for everything, and it's gonna say,
like, this is to be- you have boss team, you know, this is to
the team, to the team. You can, uh, make it.
Thank you. If it's me, I'm looking back into the finish,
and I hear some- You don't want to have the crap in,
any code for the finish in the system.
So, let me put in what comes- So,
there's people really, can't place those pieces.
We've got to do that, actually. Do you do something?
You could designate it. And what type of,
uhh, what type of frame if you want it to be.
It's, it's not changing, it breaks, it's changing,
no? you I just, I got a plastic machine out there,
anything above 23 inches high,
or what is it, 485? Anything, out. Okay,
folks. Sheolkata?K That's out of that, and I can't look for Dutch.
I'm going to do that thing with certain lines. Yeah,
certain lines that if it's got plays, there's something that's got to be.
See you. So, next time. That's what's going to determine how you're doing it,
is that great, you know, with the light.
Yeah. Just, you know, like, please pick it up.
out. It depends on shape and my question is,
is there a way that we set either a brand new or a filter
in time with wherever it was saying? . If it needs to be removed,
that's that without your anger.
Yup. You use this method that it doesn't need to use the other method
of estimating, contract with the light,
and in need and in need and then overlap. I'm going to go over
that. And then you can walk along ahead and put that,
put that kind of moment to say, hey, at least we'll repeat it right
in the community. So, so I- You can move on to this piece 6,
main and this piece of the machine, uh, however you want this,
but you can- you can have that right in the- it's an easy feel
for all that stuff. So that wouldn't be a problem to all of it.
So, we're gonna start on the screen.
Ready. Action standards document.
Yeah, we'll start with Tony's. I think that case is gonna be,
uh, a massive. Yeah. You know,
we're starting with Tony's going to have something to be trying to figure out
how we can, we need document control in this,
or in addition to what we're- Yeah.
I thought we didn't show that problem with someone in my hands,
because I haven't been to that, you know, if your life helped,
it was tough. Go. Yeah,
he was, he walked me through, the dysphoria is going to go out of
the lane. He's talking about the idea to- He's
not a doctor. I mean, he didn't doctor control the person if I had
one. It does just that. I want someone who's mature and,
too. He's also important.
But anyway, it's really good. We want to be- You have started laying this
stuff out, and that's what everyone agrees to.
We just put it in there. Yeah. Yeah,
I think. Uh, and so I like to receive,
huh, you know I like to receive your phone and the rest of me
in standards. Uh, again, I get you.
Good. Not that. Yeah. Sorry.
It's, it's something that's lagging.
Yep. Yeah. Right now it's like,
we just- There's no record of anything we got.
We're not, we're not of where it was.
No time. I I mean, that's not good.
Yeah. Start with code instead of simple.
Yeah. Thank you, good word. Well. We'll see the code.
Pretty much out of ops, and great. So, you know,
I can't even work. Well, it was good.
I told him I was getting my thought. I'm staying there. you Past with
the past, and so he started to work with the
internet. should. It'd be nice if you'd go back and look at stuff and
see if it was tweaked or what happened.
And that's it.
I think that's a great, uh, piece of data that they kind of need
there. Well, watch game digital control over it.
If you're going to change it, it'll be like, I want to know,
What it was, uh, it went to five,
and next one later, see ya.
So, on the top. Go.
Go ahead and do an X4 out the main.
And then, just bump it somewhere. All right.
Okay. Now, we're so two things you
need to do. This is only,
like, a mass of, uh,
X4. You can literally import this back into another thing with,
I don't know, somewhere. You got the whole set.
Yeah. So. I love you. Which is how soon you think about some of
you know, you should understand something that you may have liked,
you know. You don't think that there's so many standards,
you know. So, yeah. So, if we created a written standard and
then we export once the written standard. We're going to I'm to show you
is, is that you can export this out and that could be our market.
Yeah, I'm going to do this. I'll export this out.
No. I might be also create a different,
um, shop set up here. So I've got a bubble shop set up.
So we're going which I've got a new shop set up.
The shop set up will,
um. It will definitely
take the time to quickly do it.
Now, the, the, the structure of the line can labor very slowly bring.
Thank watching and more than I said,
that's the same regardless of which shots I have.
But the times would be good. So,
we can say. So we can say through a new revised shot
set up and you use that and make all your adjustments here while other
than say. . . But you can do that.
Just like you were planning on having other shots.
Yeah. Exactly. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. So there.
That's it for the bit of labor,
uh, labor. . . . All of that is,
we'll give this whole test off.
So. But you could literally go in here and
make block changes if you knew what you were doing in the code.
Yeah. That's a Is a little bit That easy shot.
And people do that. Very rare.
Very rare. Uh, but because you have got a blend of structure and
all . . Yeah. And then you've got it added.
They saw it. It's easy it's, it's better on people to do that right?
So, come on. I know you get pretty good at reading the stuff.
Yeah, but there's pretty much sections of this.
And so this is a different format. So if you try to point to
it, sale is going to be all over the map.
So you don't know that penalty.
You can start up right there. So,
you're not really okay with sale and further.
Thank you. So, who are you guys back up to do it with?
Yes, sir. Okay. Okay,
three and over. Now,
let's do a week deal. The rocker just keeps it forever.
Alright, I'll just, it's a new file.
It's over. I went back five years,
couldn't beat it. you Yeah.
Come back to the, come back to the party. Uhh,
it's, it's. It's all stored in the, uh,
drive. It'll probably not.
But you gotta be able to pull up the three years,
so like that. So there's probably,
I mean, I'm b****** and guesses.
business. But, okay,
it's very, very, very sad. The other thing is,
we're not using this full scale, and then,
It has time, it's not around, it's just in the, oh,
this would be a horrible, and it's not a process.
Now, the other thing is that it's very,
very, very large. Mark. We might have any changes to this
week. So there's some dude,
bro. He's not a person. He's interested in how,
uh, persistence and all over came from him.
So back a week. Thank you. Make sure we understand that.
Yeah. And then I'd be curious. I hear things would be better.
Yeah. Okay. That's than that. That's okay. I'm just here.
These kind of curious how I'm not thinking at all.
Well, it's not that we changed with the Eiffel box.
a a step so that we know what we're going to do.
Yeah, it's my assumption. As long as we,
we can use- use this as our standards,
the text file, to be our standards relevant,
and then I'll do- I'm gonna move forward and be attracted out.
So when we pull that, we can- this would be- to give it
a number. Just send it a- . It was a number to Rabe at
the date, and then somewhere nearly mad and,
you know, notes. Mhm.
Mhm. Mhm. Mhm. Mhm.
I know.
It's okay. We'll all next week. It's a fun to get up, take a
look at the bus. There's some jades, all the jobs that have been called
in favor of it. because if you have any of that labor or
have any of it, it's almost labor as well as that thing.
So any change that we made this for you is not here.
Thank you very much. Thank you. And how do you know the phrase is
there? Like, what if you're in the middle of a job and you want
to take off? And you'll just pick up the new one and go back-
and clean everything from it? Yeah,
yeah. If I don't have it, they said that,
yeah, it changes over me, it's fine. a little bit.
You can't even get it all by yourself. It's been a day to think
it's a big, you can't just get it and leave without setting a date
with it. Yes. So if you're a- Oh,
some estimates can you tell if dates said is had a-is had a-is had-was
had a blast and, and it-becues your- later,
we said later date for every childhood that could sit in.
Also, your only job has been estimated since-it's-it's-it's-it's.
So, what about the job? For example,
it's back to the job-it's-it's-it's-it's-it's-it's-it's-it's-it's.
And, there we have one exvisVO, 400 sec.
So, the changes that we're doing now,
it's good to go! Alright? Ok. See ya bye Bater.
I'll that. If they don't have that,
they'd send Jira how they'd get it. Ok.
Then we get it. He's like like, yeah,
he'll still have to start now. Just. We'll week. We're going to murder me
in the state group. Kind of this, but you can say it's up.
I just want you to take a lot of money,
and you've got to zoom and tell me what you're talking about.
Thank you Yeah, uhm, that will benefit both your job anyway.
But the actual compilation of the hours will not be affected.
Good. Okay. Yeah, it's automatically adjusted because there's too much
running between some of that print and handling.
Yeah, so that'll change. See Okay, we'll be there. Yes.
So the- the- the- the- the- the changes that won't be on there are
gonna be the first changes that we've made last night.
Hey, that's where we- this thing goes to this and it'll be like,
well, all the way around to the two sides.
It's actually that one thing. You know,
it's going to take care of the things that people say.
So, I guess that's a great phrase.
The labor could change on this,
but even- Even if the day is clear there,
if you change, I'll try to question it because
it's laying real good. Umm,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah,
What is that? It's really interesting, well, it can be,
uhm, yeah, you know,
it's an original set, set, but not the same as,
Oh, god, it's the, It's, uh,
say it has a lot of different effects.
It's not effective on a labor chain.
They will go, So, let's say we got six months from now.
We read it, and uh, really aren't there.
Look at all the stuff. And then we'll have all the stuff. Is there
a way to remove that thing? You can say we do want it to
be. Oh, there it is. There we go.
Yes. Yes. Okay, well, what's that?
That's not what my people could do. So, it's the most important part. It's
what we need. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Press is ready.
If going to I don't know It's not the part of it. But if
you can't be the part of it, it's just gonna get over.
Then in the business, we're gonna be getting rid of it.
That's all. All the labor and everything long together to get out of that.
So, one thing I'm paying attention to. So.
So, I'm assuming D.O.
Department of State, E.S. and D.O. would set the E.S.
on to the L.I.T.I.S. 6 for the technology world.
But E.S.O., E.S.O., E
Oh, yeah, that's good. They're out of this point,
people. So, yeah, shit, shit. Or two of them,
shit, nah, it's a bit loose. Two guys are out in the building.
Bye. I'm not gonna do that.
Statuspage, yeah, type. Press to the same. You should not be an inviscid person.
for the new video. Okay, and I just speak to you just a little
bit. Umm, maybe a bit of a mark on the issues of labor.
Dartmouth is now at the end of April. Look at the jobs part because
it don't happen. Look at the English names, fair notes.
Dartmouth is now at the end of April. Yeah, that's what it is.
You really don't- I have too many issues with that people.
My boss has really been talking about it.
And I've got a base point. And he's got so much- But as much,
thank you very much. I mean, I'm not being a guy,
I'm reading the estimate.
Yeah. Go.
Well, I don't want to, I just want to see how it's being put
together this final month,
but it still gets larger than even the following. It's, it's being less important
on each tablet over here. Okay, so yes, but we need to have this,
like, I'm going to talk for a second, I'm not going to,
I might cancel out that, so I'm going to able to do that.
There we go. And yeah, it's a, you know,
even, you know, all sorts of people out there,
you know, and stuff in the entire brain, and you make it way for
them to come and make it so you can. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
So, and then it's just like, okay. And so,
at least we're going to go to say thanks to the guys,
and being, you know, for us, it's time to do it.
So, I'm gonna, Go on that day,
we have, and he said, well, we're gonna use it, but I know I
was gonna keep it, it's gonna detect me.
So, I go ahead. . . attack by the hand of him,
so he puts him for me now, and I have to say to that
they come to you, that's what he is Check this,
I got it, you know. But,
one person has lots of the everything,
it's so dense. Yes. For instance, you know,
probably toward this year's the pie. You know what?
I've been hearing about him since. He seemed chaotic,
but I'm not even sure. Literally, actually, I was gay.
That's how you do it all. Those guys are the best.
They're all the best, they're all the they're all they're all the best.
As I said in most accounts, I'll bring and have pretty years this month
to be written. Keep going tomorrow when we jump right in my mind.
Thank you. You of course, uhm, PMs,
PTs, department management, department engineers,
and estimate of all the people that are the biggest.
Yes. If you, uh,
see everywhere you know, it's, it's,
I actually don't know about those y'all right in,
uh, okay, where, you know, a lot of people.
Uh, or two, you're worried about him.
He's going to be homeless a lot. I know. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I'll see you in the next one,
and the caption is, that's how I'm going to be sure the software,
and then just throw it out and say, there you get it. There goes.
There There it goes. Bye. And then it comes back and says,
yeah, this is the one, this is the tool where you can make
this is the one. Bye I'm using that tool and I'm not sure if
I, I'm actually make sure you go out there,
right? So if anybody asks me anything else,
I'm going to get out of this. Okay. Yeah. So it's time to look
at this while we're sitting here. Yeah. So this back to,
okay. And so the question I was asking.
Okay. Uh, Gavin.
Right. They're good. Hey Bean.
There, and it was the R. The R is the- And then we updated,
so we had a bunch of them before we took off. Mm-hmm.
And then, Steve and they added that extra fill-up weld.
Go. Well,
on the end of it, the end of it.
Yeah. Which, in my mind,
is it your departure sentence? Cheers! I would set up a conference.
Yeah. Wasn't actually what I'd do.
We'll see you a little bit. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. . Good question.
I don't want Something I've been reading.
Something I've been reading. I don't want to run a gun.
Yeah, I don't get the drawings. I mean,
I can't, I can't get looked at chakla and looked at the drawings because
I don't have a velvet bucket. Okay. Because I looked at details and I
looked at chakla. I'm not there yet.
It's just being heard. I was in this area.
We might need that. Okay. Bye. Okay,
well, this is probably in the middle. I have plenty of news over here,
and I have emails over here, and I close through it,
and I'm also looking at- Okay, I got that.
That's fine. That's Technically expect part of the revenue program.
Let's do it again. I'll you in video.
Bye Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You, you are correct that,
you know, I think it's so. So,
Other than that story, I won't be using that quite often.
I'm a bit of a late drawing.
So that's how I'm going to be. Thank you. These one-off things were out
for me. Uhm.
I'll throw the wheel in that way. Yeah, that's not the right.
Bye. Go to, uh, NCS,
one of them. There's a 59 page,
combined file. Go up.
Yeah, that's what the whole set. Yeah, it should be fitting to know I
made that when I was in the parking lot. And then there's a lot
of ways to combine this. You just combine it. Yeah, that's what I'm going
to scale on. So they pulled that one B off
of a page 30 set. Page three.
Great. Page three. Page three.
Page three is the standard details. Yeah.
I looked at all the standard details myself. So.
Any label that's three?
Yeah. There you go. Yeah.
And I looked at all of these so they have brows and they have,
Exactly, okay. These are just
standard animal-driven men of the main portion.
or, The work is still here to come. Keep it along with them.
Here they go. So, when Statuspage 3, what does he say? I don't know.
If you look at the drawings down there above my border,
I don't see. See you next it says what one?
Well, they are all different.
They don't really have what I see in that NA-T number.
That is the F. You are trying and removed.
They are mixed up, so we just pay five. Yeah,
the uh, NA-T is just nature. Be sure to,
Yeah, but that's those are individual drawing numbers.
That should be using. There's not an order in the drawing set.
You know,
so those should be that page should actually be referencing the page that he's
falling from. Bye bye. Okay, good. Go back now and go on.
Nice. Well,
thank you. You guys had an 18-year-old vote.
What's that? Which is? . . That's a number,
anything, one, one, 18-six. That's a drawing number that should be used because those
are the past little drawings listed. I'll show
you on this I that's a I'm at it. You film. Promise those aren't
in the order of being this is it.
You know, my guess is there's some that are
that's in the- My guess is category is gonna be our best
fellow model. So, he's doing a takeout. Let's go.
So, when you're going to use a theme style,
you've got to quantify the columns,
quantify the braces. Uh. No.
No. And it has to have to make separate,
so this is your turbine building,
vertical beams. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. So, considering,
you're going to get a counting on this thing,
it feels good. Uh. Bye.
Like, the total W deems the best. Yeah.
Yeah, me is totally the best. I'm going to be the best.
I'm going to be best.
That's Yeah, I still don't know.
But then they don't rank it. Oh, because when you highlighted it,
it grabbed display. Yeah.
There go. If you are alive, it doesn't, it doesn't change that.
It just goes with a 1, 3, 7, 8,
that's like it. But it still says that in that- I'm sorry.
It's not displaying. There's 370 companies.
Yeah. So,
he saw me. It's, it's 16,000.
Tons. So, he's got a shitload of more comin'.
Yeah, right now he's at, Do you know what?
He's got million in the monitor for a total of two million in the
rest. So,
stop. Oh. So,
I find it interesting as I begin looking at the hours,
12,000 hours. Yeah.
We're not even close to where we are. I wish you all a little
end up. If we trust my technical setup,
like, oh my geez. But,
so, we'd mostly, I mean,
uh, the main error will be the category,
so, that's the way it sits. Let's take a look.
I don't how to solve it. And,
uh, I couldn't understand this. This is our disease so far.
Oh, no. And, uh,
since this is going to be far, this is the emultifier cost of these.
So. Alright, so we'll see you guys the next uhm,
simply with this, uhm.
So, wait a minute. So. So,
Wait a minute. Beams are the best thing.
We can call on the line of 5-4-2. Uh,
it seems like it's 2. You have to be multi-partners wearing periods and showing
the page number you're going to find out.
Or just, it's not. That is not the best thing.
. So you got a new U12, a 542,
though, I think it's an elevation. It is.
Yeah. Alright. You Sounds like we're almost gone at this point.
So we can always pass here on the piece of rod.
Bye Always
all I'm hearing. Yeah, he's listening to all the posts right now.
Mm. Mm. Okay,
we need the next slide. We need to help us understand it.
You Which,
uhm,
so the question is,
Um, how do you figure out, like, what page is associated with what area
of work and, you know, in this sense,
essentially? Okay. Thank you.
He's listening right now.
I think there's three of them.
You have courage.
Uh, uh, uh, currently it's U.S.
Mayors. The U.S. mayors. mayors. The mayors.
The mayors that are using the tech helper. Okay. Nice to make sure you're
around here. Where they are, they're on the with different thought.
Nut instead of. Mm hmm. We are now in.
So. Go ahead.
Sedera Kingdom.
Yo, why I do like page one, which means the first love.
Well, So, this is the first one of one.
And then, like, Category, it's gonna know of either,
like, B, I mean, columns weren't doing estimate,
so. It's related to local,
like, specific, food feed or something like that.
And then when stuck by the volume,
you should be going to be anything that's attached to that.
Let's see, like, base break. All over.
Specific, right?
Cheap break. And the card is gonna be Sunday.
you I'm gonna be sure I can verify that we've got estimated to be.
It's gonna take us, I know, like, w We'll the next one. Okay,
so, you know,
for the conference,
right? I'm gonna be, what do you see that it sounds?
See, it's only all the problems with that London.
Relay it. Zero all the way to the group.
The main vendors, cause this is, this is the commons.
All we have our phones. So I,
dude, take off for one common,
only in the, like, month of fire or things like that.
Cool. Same case for the
new, the second one.
Cool. Sure, I did the take off for one.
We have one that attaches to where I've been able to find my floor.
We did it in three. It's going to be,
uhm, specific or though I did put the football piece separately.
Thank you much.
3, 4,
5. If you knew, you knew the sense would be pressing.
Eh. you ehm.
Thank And in here,
this is the very first one that locations.
Cheers! And
this is only like a comma, so we need to take out for it
in person. So this
is a standard way of doing it, or is this your way of doing
it? . . . . Take in your
process, my friend.
Umm, tell us a standard when I'm doing it,
or is this your way? It's my way,
can you? . Okay.
Okay. We gotta change it. Oh,
look, sound outside of it, find it in easy way.
Thank you for all of us. Sarah,
I think it looks good the way it is. Awesome.
Thank you, Grandma. Appreciate that. . One thing you can do is,
if that can't be set the category
to, uhh. . I don't know.
You can't be a keeper. And then all those pieces would have,
like, all the columns pieces would have, all the characters.
. . . . . But, in fact, you'd have to be the management
and if Well, I, I, um, you know, I, I, of course, I,
it's a hold on. I've said that
okay, when it turned on to where it all lives in the back.
Reviewing this all a lot is your, so,
so, so much. What you're saying is what we see on page one through
twelve will be down below sunrise by whatever
you recruit. And that's, it won't be so drastic here,
but there's tons of reporting based on it.
And worry that, yeah, you can get a poll report about it.
That's category summary. So what's the difference between reporting and category column?
Pulling it in here. That's, that's,
these are all. . Okay, so if you pop up,
do count a little bit. Pop up and category is clicked on columns.
1 B B B All you can get is the one line.
You don't get all the columns. Cause not all the items that are columns
are thickness. But if you be able to work them.
Yeah. Yeah. So what I'm saying is,
it's essentially a quick way to look at it before,
if you tag it. Correct, correct,
correct. So you're saying it's a bit open,
folks. It would have been better for some of the tag,
it's one as a call. already this here. Yes, sir. In all these associated
with gum, did I have any other copy and paste the first one on
the way down with a chemical? Yeah. All I'll have fun. All right. Yeah,
Vyz. That's cool. Yeah, you can just go up there to this,
you're a certain guy. But, yeah,
you can get this all up in the same- And so you use a
preference, Jira. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, that's it. Yeah. Yeah,
that's it. That's kind of the, sort of the category so that you can
then, let me see you call up out.
So if you click on that filter down there, you call up the computer
if you use it. Look. So really,
if you were to pull down columns right there,
it's basically a piece mark plus all the pieces that make that.
. . . . piece mark. . . Yeah, if you had them off
that. . . Yeah. . . . . Yeah.
. . Yeah. .
So . . . Yeah. . . It's easy . . . It's easy
. . have to help to treat . . . Right. . You should
understand . . . Yeah. . So .
. . You . . . What percent complete are you?
Thank you.
Uh, well I'm not far from even a spinner, you know,
there's food stuck with it. Good.
Here,
let me stop. So I'm going to be, I'm
getting this copy. It's so fun. It's a lot of service.
as soon as we uhm,
I don't even think it'll go back to it. Umm,
one of the main things I want to- look at today and look at
it yesterday, was the contract in New Jersey,
and it has just since marked the news.
Now- you here is in the middle of all one, so we can go
on and take a look at that portion of it.
So this is,
They by that news that this does get me a,
a, a, like, what they call it, a, a form of a new result
that is coming from us, but, uh. Umm,
it's, uh, it does create a,
a, a, the, the thing with all the functions,
uh, and, and, and, right. All right.
So, uh, we got to put in our schedule values and all that before
we can do our schedule, before we do our conference,
uh, or do our events. And, uh,
here's the other tab first. There's actually more money.
Whatever your takeover came to you, sir. We're called the team and they're some
change-in. And they need to put in the other information.
If you want, I mean, it's, uh, ehm. So,
what about contract items and then- Well, the new contract items are very much
capable of avenues in here, uh, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm, uhm,
uhm, uhm. I don't know simple complex you wanna do,
but even though I just need detail and I have to issue the,
uhm, where are you gonna do somethin'?
I'm 34 on MediRoute. I think that's a really great big shot,
I think. I think he's still here.
I really like I'm going to use it again with a lot of sound.
You know what I mean? Yes.
I think it's all delivered to a live-out. It's a lot to do if
you receive it. Yeah. It's exactly what it will be.
All right. Thank you.
This
is how she did it. You Yeah, this one could be some large buckets,
so that's it.
Very good. We'll never think that, but right.
They ask most of us to copy this into,
into. So.
So those categories then also
apply the project management phase of this.
you Uhm,
yes, so all of the Jira were in the fashion control and they had
bad voyages for it, so that he could, there's actually no rewarding them.
. Yeah, you're a cat boy, you can't get your cat But that private
instanceg animal bound? Um,
no O Sporty, there's no value you've seen on the whole for many seasons.
But, um,
Bob, so, the stable pass right there,
don't know if it's- And if,
All that now is historical good schedule.
So you can tie the line item on the- on the contracted-
Good night. Good night. You can voice them to a line item to the
schedule. And when you go to the bill,
they'll say, okay, that line item on the schedule is just for Sunday.
Okay. It'll,
it'll, it'll, for me, they'll send me, they'll send me the bill that,
you know, uh, it'll just cost. You Plus,
uh, Chuck's a complete, we may, we may not be able to bill it,
but at least an idiot n'er, says, here's not already,
you all, you're in at this. If you get a job,
it ain't five, you know, whatever, seven. But,
and then the time up there, we have a commercial contract,
the heather. You helps you with change work. We come back,
we come back to change work as well,
but, and show you how that go change button.
And I'll make it. Ditching orders and reaching orders and reaching as well,
I'm sorry for the magnitude of distance.
Or in the form automatically. I'm not a cleaning.
I mean, I'm not even building it in which way you want to set
the original contract value and then give you all the change orders,
current contract value, but I don't see. Thank you.
Yeah, and it doesn't. Yeah, sir. Yeah,
it has the typical number of issues. Yeah,
yeah, it was original contract value.
Okay, so. Thank you. Yeah, it does all that. Yeah. I'll get where you
guys have to go out there and please stay.
Okay. If you can do it that way today. For more about,
sorry, I missed what you did for a second. So as long as jobs
are gonna be rewritten, with. And you always, I think you always
want to know your original value.
You want to- how all the sum of change orders gets you out current,
and you want to know about the current change order,
except you're submitting. Hey. Hey. Hey. Do you guys track all that?
You've got a manual? Umm,
that's also part of my need for the rest of my life.
It's a very clear depiction of original us and chain orders in the
total value of the project.
You need a remark. alarm. Chain orders is a word in alarm.
In these submitting stages, unless it's awarded it once in the total budget
value. You can't do that, you're too lucky.
Yeah. Yeah, you know,
uh, so. Yeah, Uber. Thank you very much.
I'm here. So,
I'm in the region, you're using Pro-Corps.
We'll see in a minute.
It's your historical tool. You're going with it,
and it has a long road. Give it.
You wouldn't have thought it was the head.
Pardon me from all of us, and I'll see you in a minute.
This one's going to get a warning. It's not supposed to be gone or
not, it's better after you watch it's supposed to be gone,
and then they figured it out. Bye bye. That since we're not pushing the
files through here, and we're just trying to ask the next through here,
the actual, I don't know if that ain't going down,
or if the weather ain't being pushed through the system.
And, uh, sorry. Harvey. 7 I don't know.
I'm not going to leave it before the weather ain't down.
People were asking me. So I was only looking under a certain value we
could actually still trust. No. No. By having the system,
which about a lot of people will use for chain orders,
uhm, evidence. times.
Simple, simple things that goes through,
so. But in this section,
we're going to have to be paying. Yes.
All right. Well, it's extra consolidated and it has to be done.
Yeah. I mean, I didn't work from, like you said,
from gorgeous still. I don't make live quizzes.
Easier than the universe.
Easier than the term, right? It's- this.
It's I know what the amount of- it's kind of like it's in all
data. It's forming people up a little bit so spreadsheet to get their- I
don't know what the answer there will be no sale,
I don't know the answer. Okay.
Please just be part of any accounting person to figure out who system
stuff's in. Yeah, I mean,
I won't be. I'm gonna pick the tool and get it with me on
it. What matters, technically, whether it's credit for work,
as long as it's consistent. It's just, You know, I don't wanna,
I'd rather get it, but it's just gonna seem that I'm gonna figure out
where I am today. Good day. And
protocol is probably, uhm, You more
tuned to some of this, some of this stuff,
right? But,
. As Icards, it might be more,
you might I don't know what's the word with any- Might be,
sex orops it might be. But ahaha.. Nun Goose!!
I hear the person who understands the finance that
best says the form of a spirit. Here. It's
me having a boyfriend, and she's,
uh, she's super busy. Heh. Thank you.
We've got a hand in cheek.
.
Notice there's a routine there too,
so like, I used to try on the same. Okay,
I'll be over a table and shut up and it should be improved.
Okay, you should only be held on their action portion of the contract and
not be held on a very good lesson of the presentation.
So. So, If I was successful there,
even though they don't write a language, um,
on all the materials and everything, they'll be able to see your record.
So, we've got to come.
You might be okay. So,
there's our schedule about an inch there.
So, let's close this. We'll see you now.
We have a total schedule. We have to approve change orders to the contract.
No approved change orders to the contract. No approved change either.
So, if we were to- I'm not feeling this now that we've had the
invoices. There are no invoices that won't leave
me. No approved. Now we have all the information at the top.
Put them in our baits, uhm,
or put them in. In fact, sure. Engage is great.
Of course to use right. Bye. People are superior in daily revolution.
But we don't go in those kids, right? Yeah,
they're not being there in the top bag, but. Now play with the bottom.
All we're doing is, we're either putting it up or saying,
we're not gonna say that Jira's was 50% percent of the way we're gonna
go right there. Let's just reach one,
yep, great. Yup, yep, yep.
Let's look how long we want to listen. What's that?
I think we just want $5,000, so I'm really good at the current,
completely work. And just putting $5,000,
you're getting it even more. before. You're getting $5,000,
or if you think he's doing it,
yep. So, it's pretty.
We're ready. It's pretty simple on my, uh, thanks for this.
I used to have them where,
you know, all project managers did not do.
You the actual wheel, but they had a different version of what,
you know, so they would do this, then what's,
what, because it's very certain. . . And then they would send documentation
to the lady that I did.
. . And she had all the numbers that she needed.
. they should give you a little texture to their documents.
What would she do? . do? .
. Does this block or do anything else in the background?
. . Um. Like what?
. Let's say, uh,
I'm 100% influenced,
but I'm still working on Could I actually work on it because it's 100%
influenced, but it doesn't set blocks at all. Not at all.
Not at all. Not at all.
It's different. You're the first to know what we love through the end of
the month, so it's not that accurate. Today,
at the end of this month. So close that panel.
Can I tie this to shipping?
Like if I say, I'm 100%. And ship will you fly me in the
hood? If, if, uh,
I'm shipping what I'm on the stage room,
it's time to ship me. And, yeah,
I think I'm tired of doing this, but I don't want to ship it.
I want to ship it. So,
you guys gotta follow me on the list. Yeah. Yeah. So,
give me the drop down to the top now, and it reports,
do the 702 to the 703.
3 2 7 I think that this is a pretty marked version.
You can't just sit down and use your mother. Hey,
eh, eh, eh, and you have to go. Hey,
eh, you got to go down. Right here. It's good.
So there's your typical first page, right? Yeah.
Run the seven and three as well. Thank you. Your
typical second page. So,
erm, yep. So that's,
It's a really easy to use.
It's really easy to use. You know, it's gonna be easy to do.
are well. The thing about this is you don't break a spreadsheet.
Rishi. Everyone's a spreadsheet for this,
right? Uh, you don't break a spreadsheet here.
We used to always do that. And just like, okay, next month.
Now. No. It seems like our links to the prior pay gap where I
was broken or so, so my screw up formula and Vince did not flow
in for. Yeah. We'll see the last moment,
right? So this, we're going to be inside.
Sorry. We're just not making sure your plates are available underneath.
Can it, uh, can it track what I did the previous two months?
Oh yeah. Thank you. Can it project what I did the next five months?
They're both projecting the thing for you.
Oh, the thing, the schedule building on there.
How much you should be on. So, really could run 19 plus five.
Can you do that? Yeah. Yeah. So let's,
let's move. Go. Great to change order, Stephen. So,
is that our main today for you guys to do two plus five?
Bye-bye. I'm pretty sure
somebody in the county doesn't. Yeah. I think it's not people who do the
longer books in the afternoon. Umm,
yeah. Yeah. Marcus, if you know what I mean.
And Marcus, if you know what this is the,
this is the, this is the real test. I'm gonna have a little bit
of a feeling this is 2 p.m. with the shop, and we did it.
Pass and I'm gonna make a little bit of it. I did it.
Yeah, I'm, uh, I'm cheering the,
the intro project of the 5 acres,
and I'm 10 days behind. Not in the room,
I'm flavored. I'm a bunch of stuff.
I can't see any of it. I can't believe you can stay right here
on the show. It makes no sense!
Next. I say, you're not project management at that point.
You know, if you're not able to be close to your real kind of
stuff. So,
do you know that?
I'm changing the numbers in here.
You have to change the numbers in here, too. You can do this. You
have to change over the weather, until that,
that. Close that, you have to second bend,
don't stave. Then close that out of here,
bust it all the way out of here, get it out of there,
give it a change orders at the bottom. So,
this is your change order problem. So,
this war will stay in pain with the contract of the grossing.
You said you were sending me- Yeah, change order dude.
Supplier, you don't have to feel like most people don't.
. That's the same, if you're right, you should,
you know, change order and uhm,
everything I'm basically just sitting at all, and I'm not gonna tag me more
than good. Good. Good. If
you get it, put it in. So. . . You apply it in there.
It's basically all right. So,
it's such a contact. If you did,
put that in there and it's somewhere shorter.
You have a report available. Here's what this guy says.
That would be already in here. He'd be able to have it in our
book. He changes that in his days.
Thanks. Change will cause his dollar check.
This is the movie in here. Probably since last time I was here.
You could be uploading them about,
or hit the cost of them next to it.
It's saying it's going to overrun. Right. So,
if you have a change order that's in your estimate,
you can review. You come from me.
That's my estimate. I'm following that over in the year to give you a
breakdown. Basically, make sure you're later at other.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. So,
that's really cool. The other thing you can do here is we can just
do new, you know how they want the bright day and once they're working
for a little bit. So, you can do moonkeeper and put in your bright
day research. Um, and describe it out in the end.
you you have the option to break out,
but you have the option with all that change order when you're sanding it.
. And whether you include the breakdown or you should do a lot of
stuff like the ones through the breakdowns. So thanks.
If you have multiple categories you can add.
The seven days and sub-the-seven days, if you want just to show you the
seven days, not all the detail you can pull across like that.
It wouldn't pull this. You use it for us or you can copy for
restment. Actually, this did not be for restment,
so I put this to it. So, such
as pulling over, basically, your material,
your labor. Thank you Thank you.
And then any type of, uhh,
other type of breakdown, so,
like, once a month, you won't. So.
So, So it's like a little bit of the assembly,
but I see the way it's pulled on over your toes. And then you
won't feel so, you know, it's like, no. That's just funny.
6,500, Rovo, 14C,
it's all about $38,000.
So I'm changing the brand new, right? Or the outreach period.
Good bye. I didn't want to show them 3.03 hours with 8,
at 8 and worth 48 hours. You know,
I want that to be 85. So I want the other one to be
$100 an hour or something. So you can put it right here if you
want to. So I mean, these are cost members.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm driving here to do the change order eventually you want to
have some, you know, cell numbers. Yeah.
Yeah. For sure. Uh, that's why you can change your look.
Uh. Uh. Actually, it's pulled a bit out of the mess of the
summer. So, it would be,
it would be, Uh,
selling companies would work, so. So yeah,
if you have had it, then this is if you wanted to,
if you couldn't, So you're telling me there's cost fields and sell fields in
the estimate? Mm-hmm. So you got to go back up to base setup to
fix them. . . And then there's just,
like, when you're doing the estimate, uh,
I'm not really looking at corner of the estimate. There's, uh,
there are bottom colors in the summary. That's the that's spread as you like.
Then we have a look at some, and then you do all your markups
and your hats and everything that's in there.
And. and you get your shadow,
of course. This
is where you can wrap it up in the bottom of that breaker. I'm
going to make it. . And you see
you're dropping over there. It's been a long time.
So once you do this,
uh, give the chain order to pull out from the estimate.
Thank you much. Yeah,
I'm $1,000, that's what- Yeah,
I'm $1, that's what I'm gonna do, I'm gonna little bit of water,
right? Without being right,
I'm gonna do much. So, you know, something Just give me a minute.
Okay. Alright, so you have to leave me there.
I think we're gonna have to have a chat about more catch-up meetings.
The difference. So that
would dwell on the gate.
Ee-e-e-e-e-e-e. The I just didn't ee-e-o-y-e
or not. But you say Egyptians by the way,
it's a Still a
little bit. Ehm. Absolutely not. So.
Good job. That's it. I'm looking for the part of this,
part of the equation to determine the margin.
Right. for the cost of seven. I buy them myself.
They did so. They aren't directing me later.
So, they're good. Thank joining us.
It's a number that we're supposed to,
to stay in. We can't go below serving on your target.
We'd rather not ten percent partial. March 11th. I said $100,
March 8th, and then I said $100,
and $25.
So, Usually, trying to stay at a small tax or some market,
and our market percentage is very due to getting a 40% increase.
That's the cost, and that's the sell.
I mean, let me write this down for a second.
So 46 down on the cost,
62,000,
62,100.
Yeah. Good. So,
that's the hand you're looking at, here's the bottom.
Here. That's the hand you're looking at.
You Well, I'm glad I started that.
I can't believe your work matters. It's made me compliment.
That's not how
that's a 20, 6% movement, that's not perfect. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. If you go below certain marks and there's problems,
I'm not sure if you and if you go over to certain marks.
All And they question,
they may question to me. Except if you're in police, just absolutely.
I'll do it I like having,
hmmm, hmmm. I'm getting a Labour fight.
I'm a From Auto-Java, I'm going to play first time.
Okay. But of course we guys,
tonight, that is where you expect to get an answer back on the
change order. Okay, good. Good That drives reporting to you here for us.
Umm, Virginia, New person was.
Just have to say a second. No more assessments.
Just to pay help or pull them out. I'm going to be familiar with
what he had just said. Of course, but he didn't even get reported.
Automated reporting. Here you go.
I'm going to get better. Okay. I'm going him y'all the ones I need
to really get to check on. So, Thanks.
Are
you guys estimating your own chain of h******? I guys enjoy this video.
Please subscribe to Bye! If you don't buy a cast, then you can listen
to your own chain of h******. Alright,
start up your cast, and then it's good to be, Mark up on that
job, it's 35%, but the margin on that job is 26%.
Yeah. you The accounting people
will talk to you typically in margin with.
Thank you.
Yeah, that's the best of us in the province.
We need to live with the markets, we need to get that product.
Alright. But if you have a 35% margin,
be a much higher market in the US as well.
Thank you very much.
If Mom was in here, he would be very good at the markets.
Thank you very much. So,
it's funny because I mean, coding with villagers,
they actually won't be. you If that thing will mark up,
it'll mark up better than us. No,
just their spurtling shield.
field. Especially like the other people,
uh, finance people. They don't like that word,
it just, you know, bark at campus.
so here, marginalism, what their focus is on.
The difference between the cost, the sole cost of it,
so. So, Oh, gross. . .
I need to, uh, interview some AI,
so you know that type of a word. It just tries to go out
and I call the cops too. Thank you. Thank you. Alright.
And that concludes of season. 7 4
minutes in the end, sir. It's like,
oh, we're gonna let him get back in contact with him.
He through a lot, I don't know, it's here to bat. Bye!
Oh, please, I'll include him on one shaker,
three second shaker. the reason I'm in the trailer.
You
hope that basically the client needs to change
the word, uhm,
but in great sense. You know, and we'll get over to your change orders
and tag it to this my line, you know,
give this a lot of money based off of that new change.
Thank you much. I'm going to request that this is really the
most pleasure that should be on. Oh. Is
there a place you want to change or is the proof going here and
say, yes, the proof has much money. Yeah,
can I mail or I'll show you something? Yeah,
so there's, uh, can you go do that?
Can you, uh, add your physical change over request?
Thank you Peace. Peace.
That's why this, uh, is, uh, it's great.
Yeah. Nice going.
. . Let's go inside and watch him move on the chain. I'm going
to encourage you to go on the chain before. Thank you very much.
Now we're about to change our orders,
and each one needs to see an answer today,
see from today. Let's answer people. It wasn't approved.
You leave me- It was approved.
You don't change it to the contract,
right? You you're out there, and you've had to get it to the- would
you ever change your order? You Or would you ever allow that love and
scared of a value, so that it's- where would you be able to change
people's dollars? Right there.
We'll in the next changeable cost. What is this for?
I think we should do change people whatever you want.
Alright, Steve. Okay. We'll type one up and rally.
Bye Okay, we'll just do our track later.
Yeah, and it must be a little bit simpler.
Bye. You
can think of it. Never stop by the university.
to you.
J-Mylover, so that helped them succeed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Good,
This would be great, but it wasn't bangers.
See, there's nothing going on here. Is this a push to the system,
or is it manual? You know what this is. It's manual to listen.
If you guys can push this video more,
really, it will be about, I have,
I guess. And, um,
Portland, that is literally a half mile away from,
uh, Umm, Umm, Christmas. Thank you.
And, I knew this guy on the side.
I went out there about two, but it must get out of here.
Six years of heavy, they were talking about- So,
You know, they said duration, and they got the purchase orders,
and the receipts, and the inventory transactions,
and the elective, their fulfillment decision. If you, And they've been saying a lot
crazy about looking at this great integration. We have two months to get on
out there, like that is. You've been, you've been talking about this,
didn't you? The integration, you've blown it out and say it's all great.
They've been, they hardly does anything. There's so much that can be integrated here,
but where are you gonna do it? Thank you. . There's,
I haven't taken you anywhere you want it to.
Nobody's written the characters. Mhm.
No, son. Ah, ah, it's serious.
Mhm. Mhm.
Mhm.
Mhm. Mhm. Mhm.
Mhm. Mhm.
I'm sure.
We've never finished up with the chamfer.
Mhm. I'm going to turn it into a,
All of them. I see how busy she is. This is where a lot
of companies have messed up in this video.
You this is a function of the investment because a lot of companies are
only in business, plus the partners,
the best of either U.S. or anything. If you're,
if you're against some companies and they will abide in
a project management business.
. . . . . which is really how we root this.
It's weird because the downside of this is this payroll line that
I can prevent. I just need to be tracking the job,
which is why,
it sounds like, I mean,
there's one that doesn't work out in somewhere.
Okay, it's tons of editing there.
you Okay, I'm gonna talk to you this morning. He is doing this in
history. He is in Vietnam.
He ain't f****** it. So he is in history.
Yeah. And I hear him still sitting.
Fortunately, my father began checking to give you a last name to every
chop chop. Come on. Yeah,
so I was happy. I asked Chuck,
and I said, well, he doesn't use the template at all, and he's a
beautiful guy. We're going to use him to this. So he does all of
it, whatever he does, but he manages to use it this year,
but in this way, yeah. Probably it's sense that there are many of this,
because we gotta take this and get me this thumbnail there.
Yeah, so I'm basically- See you Thanks for the good of this one.
This is great joke for you, but I don't like this one.
Two PMs that are involved are molecules here and co- so they can mark
or shop, that's the goal. They work in tech,
uh, kind of stay out of this stuff.
Yeah. It's great. It's the host week. We're requiring our field crews to put
their time into field management.
Uh. Well, They should be,
should be tracked in business.
So you should have, you're not on- Bye You should have a report
that shows pending. So there's some,
I don't think this is gonna be you, I think.
. . . . distance utilized, uh,
of less humidity like that, uuuh,
is . . . . . . . . . . Thanks for watching
and I'll see you guys later.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
Anything else sucks? What do you think?
If you leave, I don't know how to,
I don't know where just the people are. If you need somebody to help
with that, like a consultant,
there's a link. you need that where Ian Baseview is out there by that
I'm never called up. And she's kind of a semi-retired.
Bye! But Baseview was the, umm, was the,
the child that technically- Definitely.
He used for Vista and,
and, uh, and Technica.
And so she very used Vista really well.
She does. . I'm not quite as well,
but, uhm, she lives in Vista River. So she's helped a lot of my
clients transition. transition with the Vista to help them get
the two working together and she really loves it.
Let's go. You know, you might need to be a survivor.
Trust is pretty good, but it's just,
like, we have so- much going on and they should pull out the fire
and work out these. Yeah. So a lot of our experts in those areas
are just trash. Thank you much. Yeah. So we're gonna try and do our
own shit on the side. It's there. Give me that sort of thing.
Thank Okay.
This is a good tool for, uh,
this one, this is my tool for it.
Thank you. I love this one, I don't know,
but it works well. So, yeah, it's been tracking.
It's been really easy to erase it. We'll read these through my- I have
a pain from this. I mean,
technically, you have the- she's barking and saying,
you know, if she has- she's doing a different area.
She's doing, uh, I don't want a third area in the house because- Thank
very much. Here, and then also,
she's doing the best of it. And it's the idea,
so it would be done in a third area as well.
So but But, you know, if you've got a deal with what to do
with this, this is a very cool video. It's very simple in the site.
So you can actually point out, please. You can use a particular site,
even though you don't have the performance that she has all the numbers in
her. Which is kind of a, Oh, I'm over-working with,
um, at least the projects that me and Mark are working on.
Yeah, I can vlog all the chambers in here.
And, And it's pulling in the original contract value,
and he could never run in. Um, and this is our percent complete and
this is what I had this past month. We're not going to be doing
anything. Sometimes we're going to get a new part of your contract value,
and we're going to get a later point of the thi- We're sending a
couple bills with it. Oh god, that changed my name.
I might see it like this, this, this. I'll see you through the breakdown.
Something can you go in last night's? Yeah. Yeah. You can't even have to
see how the enforcement is already in the agency,
but it can't be possible. Well, uh. you You can also look like,
um, you know,
we do too.
Thank you. So, the M was,
uh, and so, uh, the M was one of the three.
And then, like, okay, that's number one,
the other. Thank you. I don't even know where I've been paying this,
right? Yeah. Right. I mean, we thank you very much. Yeah,
so they have a lot of names, right? So, they have a lot lot
of right? right? You have to get that,
they have number one. Examine it,
yeah. We should have a triple about that. Here's where I'll sew.
Um, but yeah, you- . Yeah.
Yeah, three months
in. We'll you in the next and then I'll pay for 90 days.
Would they be less than an emotional one? You have to go back in
my flat, which affects two and three. you Yeah.
Yeah. Me too, me too. Me too. Yeah.
So, uhm, awesome. See you.
I heard it. I heard it from the Strawberry Stones.
Yes, it's been actually been helpful to do it.
But, maybe it's a little new. You think we're going to continue to do
this in a minute. Okay. Well,
we present MediRoute in the shop leading to MediRoute.
So, uhm. you look at it, and uhm.
I don't like Jira's, like, this is the only use method.
I honestly like that. Bye. Okay.
I think it's better to shop. Okay, so that's been the final.
So then the other, I love And Bitbucket,
send it. Or you think they're gonna have it.
I'm gonna start with several people. Man,
if they're not in the shop, you know, at this facility. So, thanks for
your time. Okay, eventually to the point here.
I'll see you guys in next video.
Bye P.M. over the shop and the field buildings.
Eventually that has to be separated and it has to be.
You just to work right.
Then yeah, we can move on to the table.
Good evening. I've been along with you. Yeah.
So, deep man, there's over there. Are you going to run,
this is your type of thing or not? Probably not.
They're going to stay in place. What do you have? You need such a
waste and they don't have shops like ours in the bottom,
so they come here in the next week. It's completely different.
I'm not very used to it. Umm,
all of their shops are ran in my field personnel,
so the field people come in and they use the shops and the tax
shops are much good. Every time that they take,
uh, stop, like, really want to do it,
like, set, you know, operator,
do what it is that it, you know. Bye! I'm talking about PM Uncheck.
You think of Lauren, he'll just do his wisdom.
No, because, uhm, we're going to cast,
They're doing these, and they pushed that,
pushed that on us. So in fact, they came here,
and we have tech already in place.
is and they said,
oh, it's unique for this operation,
but everything else runs out of 10 years.
We'll in the next and haven't been,
you know, so it's like, okay, the world is moving very quickly to OS
7, uh, offshore side,
you know. Yeah. All of these, these are new ones. Think of a long
one, sure. We will be doing it in tech,
no. I'm happy have a great And little bit No.
This is going to do what I have in the rest of the moment.
Okay. Let's see if we'll finish with us now. Let's go.
Yeah. Okay. Estimating teams,
since you guys are here on the call today,
uhm, considering that you guys might proceed.
See you. If you have any basic questions on it,
we can potentially be hungry. And all of a sudden,
you're this right. So give everybody Very
Thank you very
Not, uh, they cut off for a second as I switched the mics over
to the game. So I'm gonna say,
uh, what's on the sh- mics go-z first time,
6th all over the deal. Just like first of all,
eh? Umm, u- kill it, hmm. Like the sizes that are not in the
database that we push labor against them,
or are you talking about labor code?
Go. No,
certainly a size that, uh,
update, I guess, to create this thing,
fix your room, house for work. That's all I got.
I don't know what to do,
but, uh, it's not going to be something.
That's all I got. As far as cheap as I was painting.
I'm just going to you some of the, uh, uh,
nations where you can be. Hello? Okay.
So, I have to throw up it.
It's been a great time. It's what it was. No passes. I'll see you
It's not ending. It's still in process.
Now it's not so, uh, I'm supposed to follow on you guys as well.
I hope you guys are supposed to be updating some of this. Uh,
but I guess there hasn't been a clear
communication between who has time and who doesn't.
But, uhm, I'm assuming you're talking about
the stainless sizes, uh,
considering. I'm ready. Some of these stainless sizes that
we have in here have zero dimensions in them.
soon. So,
no, we haven't met with all of those folks.
As of yet, and I'm not anything that- is defined in here,
has a group pushed against it in the last few days,
uhh, with some- the metrics have been made since I had adjustments too.
Just keep it gone to the light where we pushed against it,
what will be the same as carbon. Yes.
Okay, grabbing for those, same as the right now,
since we are not having all the size of it.
Can you turn both? This off, so we don't get,
like, missed. Uh,
to, like, what if not, look at this piece,
so it's, like, and.
Yeah,
Yeah.
Any dimensions broke out in here. Uh,
so, for right now, these ones aren't active,
it is so beautiful. Yeah,
I think that's when it's in the big panic.
I hear brother, but he deleted the brain distancing
brain from all the beings in the place. Stay safe.
Yeah, and then, yeah, also,
and I know that that's the first, and he started creating one right now,
we're missing that. You So, I mean,
I think really, just to finish everything on this now,
this campaign, and to leave it pretty clear.
You Yeah, and the biggest issue with this having it in the,
in the carbon size, and having just the seamless grade cloth.
well. my house is, uhm,
it's not being populated as,
as the carbon, uhm, yeah. We gotta leave.
It's not even differentiating over what,
but that's having a different shade. We can push it through labor against that
shade of time. And. You can keep carbon on one,
on one plane to keep the stain with the objectives on another.
Uh, so, if this is something- I love this.
I'm putting that block of you guys down because we're gonna have your presence
on us so that we can get these sizes defined in here.
Umm, there's some time studies that I have.
So, with the time studies,
umm, we can do some time studies for some stainless material and see umm.
on. with the contamination reduction and changing
equipment and consumables for what's needed for the stuff.
Thank you very much. Uh,
I get back to that in my time studies and we'll kick some of
them later or push against those so that we can have that.
You uh, for the future. So,
but right now, even pretty much has to be had as carbon and
bad age. . . . . . . . . . . . .
. . blood, really for the
some aim. But though,
once we had it in there, we did push it on me.
Well, um, he did it all the time.
you Yeah, if you push the time over there,
you wouldn't be the carbon gun. I mean,
you could be your entity if you just get over there and say,
well, I love it. I'm not a repumption or whatever for that.
I think it's done so at least. Yep. I know you can do it.
If you might work with me here for a,
Well, it's a whittle.
So, uh, it's my dashboard and it's a fair one,
eh? Okay. All is it. And you'll get the funding to create some of
the estimated. So,
do it up to the world manual,
let's ask. Yes. Yeah, and point to all of those.
And, uh, I think the guys get better than that.
Most of the well. Let's go. Yeah,
I think they're not different for Phillips. We're going to have to get up
with us. But, you know, it's because you've got a background and you've got
a. Yeah, it's. Sure. Well, that's a good.
Uh. Okay.
Yeah. No, that's, uh, that's a good one.
And, uh, I made up that. So,
that's something we can, we can put it. And,
uh, we can, uh,
it as an action rate. Thank you.
In the, uh, in the upcoming future here.
So, uh, beyond the shapes and the statements.
It was. Umm, labor, portion.
Uh, is there anything additional amazing guys have?
Or anything that you guys wanted to see?
See you. Now I'm
getting started. Okay, okay. See you in the next video.
You can find some of those,
uh, flavors, but, uhm, the games are like,
you know, we've got a series. See ya.
You know what I'm gonna question,
okay? When I, uh, over,
was that someone was like, can you get here?
Yes. Thank you. So I saw the light,
like, someone was like, oh, this is all for,
uh, you know. It's not a bad idea,
it's not a bad If we can handle that,
I will do that. I'll do that. action that I call for.
OpsGenie, yeah, I mean,
this one is like this, but,
uhh, it's not. You know what I was just
going to touch on some of this extra,
uhh, work that we can have at the end.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. You know what I mean?
Put Paris to her side of the world, on the actual end of the
world. And you can say that that's the answers.
issues. I don't want to be
honest with you. Okay. So far.
If you just, just put sort of those,
uh, if asking, I think, for other action.
There's a little,
This is like, uh, I didn't listen to some of this.
I'm not seeing your phone, putting your phone in son. Kevin P.
has a video. You just gotta get a bunch of little cuts in there.
. . Yeah. . . Is that about having all the numbers of the
cuts? . It's turning on. .
. . It's in the view. . So I don't know,
um, close, close and break your .
. . So . . there's .
. . there's time to go through So .
. . the you're so near .
. . and then . . . and open up to this part summary,
uhh. you see that we have cuts not being here
for coats. Now .
. . this might be On the later side .
. . point more than not much for two coats.
Um, so we can . . . we can make adjustments,
make that little bit more . . uhh,
but there is already that whole chain .
. . in there . . . as for the we can .
. . is that what you are saying .
. the timing quote . . .
so the value of the chain is that something we
can . . . something we can .
. that's I will say, if you request this Sighing .
. . in a front end .
. . separate . . . umm,
working . . . like shit I .
. . so .
. I wonder if he wants that. So he's saying,
essentially, if he has a plate that has nachos in it,
obviously. Yeah, we remember there was more,
I think, yeah, they're trying to accomplish a time,
uh, the- I think we need to go ahead with things,
uhh, so it's- so people go to the end of the scope.
Yeah, we have to do that, and it turns out to happen if it's
not- I'm sure how it is, but, you know,
typically- so they're gonna be the scope of the width of the flange,
and it's- I mean, 4-H is in a way that because it doesn't really
know how deep it's going, okay? Uh,
that's right. So, I've been just as 4-H's.
So- I'm playing, you don't get 4-H's.
I don't want to remember what it does for the other shot.
I don't know if I don't make a witness that dry. Bye. But,
yeah, a lot of people can just put a notch in ignoring for about
such a few candidates. Small notch. Thank you very You
should be able to challenge her, okay? You put it in as a fight.
Very good. We'll just- Yeah, two inches and two inches,
so you basically get four inches, no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no-no If
I've got any thicker notch out than that, then I, I don't have to
be okay. Or, a lot of people say,
cool. I mean, two inches, I mean, So,
something used to make one is a cool little one,
cool. You know, the truth is pressing big beside that.
Whatever works in it. Yeah. Thank you. If,
if, if anything that you're having something manual for,
I'll be by, okay. There's no- I can't be kind of like that.
He said, just encourage them,
and if they don't manually put it, go ahead and do it,
or maybe- really, really burning, or the million hours in the hours for peace.
That's opportunities for,
and I think that's what they were saying. I love you. I love that.
That's opportunities to change stuff. They just need to keep trying to
what they're doing. And then, let's go make changes.
and so on. Yeah, in one thing you guys can
do to help us on the estimated side.
Bye. It is, um, if there's estimates you guys are looking at it and
you've noticed there's a lot of, umm,
there's something reoccurring that. . . It comes up quite a bit that you
can potentially have to have some extras.
Umm, I know we have camera in there.
Umm, it can be- I they look in one- one extras,
yeah. I bet they can. It's possible. Umm,
slow. So,
right now, we're being adjusted.
I have to do.
No. Last time we didn't defect the training.
So, not alone. It's active.
So, right now, it's going to,
default and,
uhm,
which, even, uhm, I love it. Thank you for yeah,
five hours, uhm, I going to go up for two-teens,
let's just stand up on the river. So,
let's see if we have- You see how long they are,
so you guys don't stay as much.
Uh. Bye! No, just don't bend that kind of work.
You can take your ADSS and show it on your ADSS.
But,
essentially, that one would be,
ah. But,
most pieces of this show are that much enough,
and again, just be well. Thank you,
Bob and I, again, and. You have additional labor in here,
cause that's going to be a lot more standard. And he's like,
oh, I'm going to step in.
Yeah, I'm not sure. Yeah, yeah. I think you're an expert.
I'd like to read you Thank you.
Okay, well, now I'm just going to draw a few quotes to say to
everyone. Yeah. But L-A-P-E-S-S,
most people do that as an estimate actually.
Yeah. Well, I'll let it, There are not a lot of pieces.
That's also a fact that I put it somewhere. Yeah,
so that's, that's what we can, we can look at adding,
We can talk about some extras of,
uh, essentially additional labor
to add to me. Each one of them,
uhm, is the other way I would look at it and it's going
to your asking summary and,
It's going to your task today.
Later details, going to your wellness.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Yeah, there's adding a certain percentage
to the wellness that you have in there.
Um, Yeah,
you can get into manual overrides enemies.
Well, it's the only thing about doing this here,
and I'm just gonna be, Yeah, you can be manual overrides.
To do that, everybody has to make me change that up.
Because now, Dave, this introduces an ecosystem.
Let's see. Once in a while,
do the bend. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're something that isn't very internal circle,
something you shouldn't use. So like, you're presented to a lot of 10% easily
with 75%. But I keep wondering,
why can't you do that? That's it. So
I got these columns. They're harder than all the rest. I want to put
them in 65%.
No. The regular is maybe better than that.
Yeah. Can you do that? Not what I'm gonna do.
See that? See you right there. You should.
You should meet it, uhm, because if it's additional whaling,
if it's additional, uhm, uhh.
And all of the processes for every single piece is in
the labor case. So, essentially,
I shouldn't have- Yeah. Thank you. But the intent of like,
uhm, you take it like the rails.
Do you want it a lot of noise for any of that? Sure. Or
do I get it? Yeah. Alright. So, usually on that,
I said, I'll go over there to those stars and the material,
and I will pop it in and play it. Yeah.
So, let it back and create a spot.
So, theoretically, you should really have to go home,
so you can find some material. You could come
in here and one off, and he said, I don't know about what that
said right here. Yeah, okay. Okay.
Okay. Yeah. There was another thing
I was thinking about being out of preview.
Thank you. Oh, I can play there was another free thing,
and I sent it out. And this time of year,
there's so much trouble breathing that's going to be a ton.
I'm going 3D book on it. I'm going to do a 3D in that
as, as a,
uh, s in the next year.
Thank you. Umm, I'll see you're going through the labor case,
which is really about breakfast that you don't think about.
Uhm, I see. I think the labor could answer a lot.
Uhm, those are the two main ways of doing it,
so it makes sense. . . . . . . .
. I'm doing it multiple different ways.
So, like, that they are basically,
you don't burn anything out of a souscatcher,
you can't burn anything but a hea It's,
uhh, I've done, uhh, I had a radio.
Thank you.
A, but then I have an A in for,
with 3D on it. So, uh,
so that we got the, that's what we're gonna choose that.
It's- Say anything you want to do? Uh,
I just like it. I like that. Okay,
so you get the last kind of winter summer choice.
Yes, yes. Yes. Whereas other,
other functions like, uh, North or Southern,
they're just going to say, look, if it's done for each and a half
or so and more, be, You know, they're making a mark.
They're also pretty nice, and they just take it into the native.
They send a new cut up using their ass. Thank Thank you.
Yeah, I'm saying one of them.
She's out. I think I have a few little stuff in there so I
can do another one. Yeah. And then,
Can't screw up. There's another way to do whatever you guys want.
But, I'm kind of wanting to, I'm gonna better get into that.
I got it. I got it. it. I got it.
I it. I got it. I got it. I and not every piece.
I do like to make sure that they require us to do this,
but that's true. That's a multiple, multiple types of how they can do something
down so they can pick that up. And you can still roll when you
have the rest of it, actually. . I don't think it's gonna be a
Okay.
Yeah, that's another thing I can do sometimes.
I'm sorry. My studies are, um, yeah, uhm,
ehm, ehm,
ehm, ehm, Thank you. It is a little
bit more difficult, though. It's a bonded extrapolation factor that really wants
well and free. Really? Regardless,
it depends on things sort of play that are with and the length of
the play as well. I'm usually going to just go for a wait.
as you can see. It's the best in making sure of everything.
Umm, you can look at the sort of photoshop.
That really doesn't really tell you,
uh, it doesn't tell you a whole story,
because it depends on the things, uh,
yeah, ah. What do you think? Just,
you know, I get prepared for that. It's a lot more basic spot on
them, but that's literally the best we want. Well.
But, I'm
not, uhm, Kerberin, I'm saying this. It's, it's, it's, it's. Our
living, um.
I have to find that. Is there a lot of media?
We don't really get the display, right?
Do you know? . Yeah, no, goodness,
ladies. Umm, we can't answer the answer to anything even.
Umm, I have been to you guys in the- I'm using a very interesting
assembly that we set up the last time, uhh,
the other cues here and the secondary question on that.
Umm. Bye Now if any of you guys said that I knew you were
gonna show me some of these. Bye bye.
Alright. Thanks and have a good day.
Bye Yeah,
sounds a bit big up
to me there for especially by this one this stuff.
Love. Uhm.
I know that you like, uhh, if a lot of people ask me to
do a lot of interviews and stuff, I can think that he's a parentic,
except. So you could go through a standard, can I? Because all the time,
that's certain. Yeah, yeah. And just stuff like this,
and then it's short frames. Yeah,
it's just, uhh,
we have features that are built out of the box,
Loom, Jira. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. of stair straightener moments that he do those here.
I mean. Can you see what that looks like?
Cheerful.
Cheerful. Tying. Cheerful.
Hold on. It's-it's saying
No that nothing-it's gotta be said. Everybody i'm all over with a Smither bland.
It's a It's great.
And then we should be able to change it and learn from all that
different size. See you.
Where can we see the label if it's playing?
Don't you dominate your estimate and apply the label?
Whichever piece you choose. Mm.
You
Yeah, so this must be done on a rise,
right? I don't know if you can figure out how to lengthen this there.
Try to lengthen. Yeah, that's what we're gonna do.
So, there's been stair types presented.
You've got pants there, you've got them, you've got them cradings there,
you've got them, you know, they're crickets. Yes. And concrete stairs,
what that chair type was, put it back on chair type,
and pick it whether you are ready to complain.
Oh, I think, okay. Good. And then the top of the chair you're talking,
pick which, whether you want the channel, the instant channel,
or if you, uhm, answer them It calculates all the language to do all
those things. You should put in the frame,
or you should really calculate very much your simulated bomb.
Bye-bye. If you will,
dump in all these line lines. You say, how many you got at the
bottom then? Time to turn. Okay.
That you got your, your standard of the-
I suppose,
yeah, there's a lot of energy.
So, look how I feel this way. See you in the house. No. 10.1
there. Okay.
Umm.
you So,
you know, if you're a bad guy,
you're going to have to fight all those lives,
and then you're going to have to fight. Bye. Hey,
Thomas and Tom, I'm going to pressure you.
There's me. Okay. Good. I
don't know what I'm using.
Uh, uh, these are, um. You Yeah,
we're really speaking about it a lot. I like it too for,
um, estimators that aren't as seasoned.
Yeah, because it's basically a check. CHAIR YELLEN. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Yeah, yeah. They,
they, they playing this a lot.
I didn't play the game. remember 7 8 Uh,
5 1 3 in the soil, yeah,
yeah. Last man, who had to kill us at a business job?
Thank you. They spelled it out, and then pretty much the car,
so it had to be in, so that's kind of nice.
See ya. See ya. See ya.
I was like, come with ya. Great.
Great. See ya.
Atlassian associated with great success. The I want you to buy a car.
Okay. So there we go. But there must be a step above the rear.
It's gonna be good.
You These are,
uhm,
these are all, yes, sorry,
eke, eke, eke, eke, eke, eke. and and you want,
I mean, but I mean, it's for these shops and I'll be,
I'll be in the streamers, I'll be on the plant norms.
. . I'll be in the rainless, I'll be in the walrus,
and then, like, you take a, a slam,
like, a good wine, be in the plant.
So, you can do things just to have me twice when you have a
review. You have 70 clients, and it doesn't matter if you have any clients,
so just lay yourself a bit. Thank you very It makes sense.
It's really, really, really nice. It takes a while to do,
uhm, the better to make a sense of this amount,
but it's, And once it's done,
you can go down based on some of the S.E.A.
You know, especially if you do a lot of hand rolls and spinach.
Yeah. Go.
Yeah, you know what I hear? Status, yeah. Alright. Yep. We'll be right It's
their case to the spiders,
and, you know, all sorts of people.
So, all of their issues. you And,
you know, a lot of the shops I'm getting to,
they're, they're doing their miscellaneous making awesome.
Awesome. I mean, I got a permanent maturity at LaborCon vases,
which they didn't do that,
but umm. you were really missing the opportunity to really
get really deep care of all my estimates.
Alright, I'll see ya. If you're a well-known,
where are I from? It's where I have to go down the journey,
alright? You can be that animal without having to do it,
or I'll just do it. Which was virtual with a set of printings.
You have to lead out.
You have to use the computer and the mouse. Umm.
Here's the coping machine and stuff I have.
Here's the hero. We'll go down here by now.
You see, you have a manual manual,
or if you're interested, uh,
we have a manual manual. We'll see in a minute. In we're being able
to find the manual and then have the error.
We're being use, sophisticated amount of element. So we're going to be able to
drag in, so that's where the drag in will have to
go. Okay. We're going to be able to drag so we're going to be
able to in,
so we're going to be We're
going to be able to drag so we're going be
able if you have a runner and drag it down,
try to, you know, draw a little bit of just,
you know. So. Okay.
Okay. Yeah.
See.
Umm. Mm-hmm.
Yeah, it's not my question, it's not one of the aspects of my opinion,
but it's making it just a big project.
Right? It's a big project. Right? There's feels nothing to be done on SMB
that can make life easier, like the amount more than it is in similar
notion of perfecting. The hours are limited,
uhm, but we're a big part of this year.
Seriously, it's so important. We'll do it. Now it. We'll be there in a
little Okay.
Bitbucket was paying me for a bit of a while,
and he was,
I'm gonna go get a couple of bits of couple of different bits of
stuff. If you don't, this one is here,
that's what it is. That's Thank you very much. Thank you very much.
More work and stuff that other companies don't want to do,
but they're all like, I'm going to take a peek.
That's great. Thank So it's like, that's probably good to focus.
You know, that's what they're gonna talk. That's what they're gonna tell people.
You know, it's like, uh, really gonna focus on,
difficult to do, and that's what I need to work for.
Well, actually, if they pick up an erection job,
that's what I think somebody else will steal. Y'all, man.
You've got all this miscellaneous that you need to go buy out.
I thought it was so warm. Yeah.
It seems low-hanging for you. Yeah. Yeah.
But you've got to set all this stuff up for it.
Mm-hmm. And you're right,
I'm going to shut the bellow on. Lovely. Yeah,
I'm worried about it.
Yeah. I was like, it's a nightmare. Yeah. There. Okay. Yeah.
I don't really show up. I have no shop,
ladder shop, you know, they just do all that stuff.
If you get this,
I've been in that shop for quite a bit. You're the one doing it
again. Yeah, yeah. Eight. I can't put on my father from the quantum benefit.
That's all. So you probably know exactly what he was,
but but he's kind of in the hand,
you know. I want to say, He's good. He's I didn't thought it was
good, but it's stainless, the momentum, nickel, silver,
brass, bronze, and aluminum. Clearly, they're all in chemistry!
Thank you. Right, so it was extremely high market.
Sure, eh. But I think if you get into the pants,
you're stuck. Yeah, uh.
you Yeah, damn it, you can walk down through the street.
Umm.
I wonder if that's the best place to come down here.
Yeah. Bye. Umm, you can look at what it was doing in science,
and get delayed by the past day.
And you have a lot of those. But you're really unclaying,
or you know, with all the pain on there.
You
And I see that there's a wonderful one. And four or five. So what
are those patterns you need? Good. Here's another one,
okay? Is it missing what we're getting at?
A picture of a clean type and we want to- You talking about right
here, this part then? Yeah. Stop. That's a show clean type.
That's a song. I'm sorry. Yeah,
you can add whatever you want here.
Be sure to hear just the buttons that catch the owls.
So if you're going to have,
if you're going to create something else here,
now you've got to create. Yeah. Something in,
umm, a labor code or somewhere else that calculates the hours of putting
the, puts our CO kit.
You see that? We need an open one on our end.
Yup. Well, you want to store this up on the uh,
probably, Yeah. Yup.
Yup. Yup.
Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup.
Yup. Yup. Yup.
Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup.
Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup. Yup.
Y Yup. Yup.
And chute, or what are you looking for?
Thank you, bro. You're going to clean that up,
so I don't want you to pressure me at the person.
Okay. Now, how do you get me to clean up?
Please if you want something.
Yep. So I've been approached by a lot of people,
so I've been shot away from it for a Bye!
So what I'll do is create a
labor operation. Thank you.
For that. Pretty much the talk about play.
Uhm,
I-I-I'm creating a labor operation for play for- College League
or whatever you want to, point that towards the new labor group,
and then you got to put time into- where that I needed to labor
against, so, you know, sure that,
right, but anyway. Everything's like cutting,
but now having- Alrighty. Yup. Yup.
That's all of me, it's background. We're working,
yeah. Would
it be only on display, or do you wanna play instead?
Uh-uh. Still anything.
Okay, so if I know about Mountain,
sometimes. Focus.
Umm.
What are you talking about? Maybe not one life.
You don't have to create the- Like, we're good to put it into,
yeah. Yeah,
that's- that's the only thing that's weird to- I it's all these around us
and they've matched our PC form. Yeah, I've done it a little bit.
With the theme fall under, you can hear it all the way in the
brain. Oh, what's it not there?
Okay. That's what I'm doing.
That's what I'm doing. you should be far cut.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
Can I put you to do that? I'm just buried in there.
I can't believe that you gave a lot. I think any more.
But, um. Boom. He is,
uh, uh,
blah blah blah blah. Yeah, what?
Bye bye. How do you want to figure this? How the time
you want to put on it, and you sort of suck flat on them
or piece. You want to say, based off.
I don't think it'll be a flat on that,
or piece on it. It's just a city that I'm very,
very lonely. So much for each other,
whatever. I don't You can do it. You guys,
plasma comes something, or anything gets thrown in the hopper,
and you take it to a station and some guy cleans it.
Forward, you do it. We'll have to go. The guy is cutting, and we've
both worked since kissing, uhm, Tina.
How do you guys? The guy is 7 lately, Marley.
It is the guy. What are you doing with the cleaning? Thank joining me.
The guy is cutting, he's not going to touch.
He's going to cut him to the next thing. The next guy is to
line with the fear, uhm,
those guys. They're- really clean as the new network.
That's for a new speaker. Yeah, that's not what it is.
Nope. Who doesn't need some point?
side. . . . Okay, better small understand what we do.
Okay, and then you get a start for the workstation.
So, okay, some of those. votes. I think division detail,
the guy who's making it, the guy who's cutting it.
So, it would be, I think, very, in fact,
you know what I I think the is, I'm here to do the separate
guy. No, it's, it's the same guy.
So, we have a, or a toilet and water out here,
and an hill. Cool. Yeah,
we're going stolen, I think, and as he's taking out,
and been trying to work, he's hitting them with a runner.
We're all eating that. Okay, perfect, very,
That makes sense. That's what we're eating, and it's basically,
I mean, we had a cow-locked shuttle.
While this is cutting, he's cleaning and pulling it off.
You'll be able to toss it into a cutter. It's just cuss.
Let me let the knife down here. Okay.
So it's coming out of there. Well, uh, some people just get to cut
and pump it up. Yeah, but you get less visible.
Here's a, We'll let it come in and check, like,
a year from now, and we'll let it change its life.
Well, hey, I bet, um, it's only two minutes on my way.
You haven't eaten yet, so just rename it,
cut and clean. Yeah, so, yeah, you could do that.
Uh, but, yeah, we have a separate ratio.
Thanks for watching. And you can kind of split that outside the level of
cut times this and then the clean out of this.
Yeah. And put your- Very, very, very within cut times.
Yes. And then both of those operations flow down into one
box. I was feeling it would be easier to make the right of an
impact, but I was saying, this is the cut clean.
Okay. Yeah. I mean,
it's your thing too, from the same way as the packaging bar,
but yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Clear. You don't have to change your- I don't have
an operation, right? Um, everything that will believe we're kidding you,
sir. Let's work. Yeah. So. So,
Yeah, you could just, uhm,
buy, uhm, uhm, buy as well.
QC kind of just aren't here. Thank you. Sorry.
Yeah. That's the check,
that's the interview. It's always been an interview,
you know. Just. . It's a 30,000,000,000.
It's good. All
right.
I think we're gonna go. So it's like you don't want to do this
right. There's no more time I can get it.
You better, right? If you need it,
you can't clean the center. That's not where it goes,
it's including the thing.
You know if you don't do that, you might want to be able to
make more operations and labor groups.
Yeah. Ah.
Look.
Go.
Yeah,
the bargain rates are good to go. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Let's it.
It's the minute it's later operations. Thank you
That's
right here at the bottom. Hello. Yes,
all done. Yes, all done. I'm going to go 10% and 5% in South
America. So, cut. So,
those, you can change the description if you want.
So, cut and clean. That's what I've got, like. Thank you.
Cause that's what's going to show you. This description right here is what's going
to show you what the time is. And I don't remind you to decide
how this is going to be just. . . Okay, this is where we're
going to get it in hopefully you can park. Yeah,
yeah, I mean, lot of friends. Always. And we'll see you Yeah.
Now you're going to get the tunnel. Yeah,
so the tunnel. I love this. The tunnel is going to be the experience.
Well, part of the tunnel will be.
I'm
leaving for a deep, wrong cusp. I'll see you in the uhh,
uhh, if we have a unit on it, it's constant.
In between, we get a case in the phone call,
yep, like, from him to him. Hey guys. I'm a guy,
so I don't really like it. Yeah, I'm a good guy.
Yeah, I don't have to keep that up.
I don't know, I'm eager to do it, uhh,
because you're paying me eager. Yeah,
um, that's me, if I'm in a break,
uhh, if it's something, I might be- I'm getting ready to start with the
text, yes, you would. If not email me,
and then I'll generally get to that blog.
Bye. Or,
you know, give me a hint, it's fun on the East Coast,
like, probably in the afternoon, when I, when I think of the time,
it's like, you know, cause you're playing out, you know.
If you have a business to come,
actually, I need to replenish some of this as far as I don't get
it. You So,
I shoot you in need of this, okay? Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. What's your even? You want to see more?
Yeah, yeah. . . . . . . . . . . . .
. . Even more as
I have. .
. .
. So that's it.
3.3 minutes, and why don't we increase for our added additional content?
We will increase it by then.
Uh, how many minutes you have done?
Three more minutes. One, two, three. One,
two, three. One, three.
Two.
Cut was,
Umm.
Face off of the breakdown that you guys had when it
was, Like, excuse me.
Suddenly, Scott was, ah,
harder than one good. Good. Bye. So that's it.
There wasn't other shit where we learned.
It was, like, a split. I don't want to,
like, put sand or something. Go! Which, uhh,
which, the products were high on each way through the boat.
So, uhm, 2-4-7-5-8.
Great. 10-0 is more by 40%.
Umm,
45-0-6-0. Umm, 45-0-6-0.
Umm, 45-0-6-0.
And then for the technical, it was high,
uh, 100 quilcet, but we're talking 4 hours,
actually, now it's, uh, awesome. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And then 2,4,
0, 7, 5, 8, Tecmo was low by 18%.
similar. You've already come back in some of that previous tape.
Yeah, yeah. Some of this,
yeah, some of this may be based on- Some of the changes we do
may be might have changed a little bit,
but I don't think we changed the curd, so that probably didn't change.
We've never changed that handling,
unless, you know, Tambourine and, uh, the, the, the, the, the, the, well, the,
the, yeah.
Yeah. Oh no. This is 10% sound fair,
anybody be back in. And then, it never sounds fair,
so I, I was just asking which ones were in one direction,
so like 7, 5, 8 projects, their minutes being used for coals,
to be used for coals, and, . Yeah.
And then the two other style of projects,
or break it.
Okay, straight kind of column,
straight kind of bleeds. So,
um, so the tech world was alive on the- So,
like, TV sets about, like, two,
three. Alright, are you splitting your indeed?
We would ten- you technically might need seven hours.
Yeah, most, but, most of them are on TV.
So, let's straighten. Unless you've done something to keep.
. . And you're sure, are basically assuming,
I'm just shocked that it's definitely being fair.
It's not taking care of So, yeah.
So, okay. Um, yeah, let's, uhm.
I'll you on the next to
that. Let's start with, you know,
meeting your point.
It sounds like. I said, I remember you, and we're fighting it long.
Yeah, so it used to probably used to go 20.5 to say,
yeah. Umm. Uh. Bye I can't undo the,
like, I'm not sure I'm getting a whole lot of those
numbers for you, cause it's like, yeah, yeah.
Ooh, small job. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Okay,
here's, here's the budget,
and that's really the budget. you I don't know how that,
how that budget is.
. . I don't know what it was. . . ah,
it was like . . . well, uhm,
uhm, most of the breakouts.
are stuff that we look at in drawings and adjust the breakouts
yet. So, uhm,
you've got I've heard in some more of the experience,
uh,
that it's been better to, well,
might estimate enough Whatever it was, was what type of spit out.
Yeah. And then actual rules would be,
will be came in for a ball shot. Bye-bye. I'm not too much towards
which are based on our experience.
Right. Yeah, we're looking at it.
based on the- you know, Ted was going to be,
uhm,
very consistent in what capital,
Detroit, MediRoute. How do you grow?
That's going to be consistently wrong. Yeah,
so if these are, if our comparisons are inconsistent.
Yes, Susan. And what that tells me is that what's inconsistent is
the budgeted number because disappearing.
Very. The linear line is very,
it's not gonna be the same, no matter how many times you do it.
So, that's why I'm just kind of, Once it's open,
it's okay, but you're okay with what we should do right now.
No. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Every single
day, every day, I know that,
maybe I don't ever say that you're worried that I would be,
like, well, surrounded up to 90 years whole number.
. . Yeah, I'm, like,
I got a thing we don't . . . not thinking about it,
not saying that they're as a server, you know,
I don't know.. Umm, they can be more in percentage,
but I don't, I'm always that gonna take.
Yes, uh. Hello. If,
if it takes three minutes to cut it, add an additional bit of anything
to it, then what's that three point when it needs to be done?
One cut. Something.
Which is a good point, too. It's going to last,
yeah. Yeah. That'd be one.
So we go. One cut. So,
uhm,
yeah. I mean, that's a little bit of a good thing that probably,
you know, more so than- the machine will be able to buy it with,
if I have five minutes then it'll be fine with it.
I just have a little bit of- with mud. Bye!
I'm literally looking to say we all care for that,
be quite honest with you. We have a process that- whatever you're listening to.
You're gonna do this same thing with burn. I can- you I
agree, make it five minutes for that kind of clean,
that makes sense. Thanks.
And then where are you going to convert image? So the bar is going
to be in the bottom right. Yeah,
so that's good. Alright. Okay. All right. I'll go ahead Well,
that'll be a different here. More and more like it'll be a percentage of
it. Yeah. Yeah. Probably some of it.
and I think we should get some more of an impression
as a status, it's uh.
Oh, and the cuts are perfect. Yeah. Used all that shit.
Yeah. Good.
It's
uh, the due passage is coming out, that's closest.
See you up, the day of this. You're back to hangin' up in the
morning. Yeah, when we did that,
it said, come on for later. You know. So he put that on the
machine today, but he actually said he heard there was a other passion,
so he put two on the machine to see.
But he said something else was coming that's going to speed it up.
I guess he's talking so much. And it's coming back and it's
going to be to add something. Yeah, I guess it's going to reach out
to you at a terminal when they hit the host. You get a little
bit
Let's start with the bridge. I'm gonna
go ahead and figure out what to do with the part.
. . . . Oh, It's all a ton of manual
lip so we're talking about. Indeed.
So we actually changed the flight,
turning to, umm, Sam and Moon.
I'll to make We'll time.
You. And yeah,
hopes are the manual. So,
yeah. So,
yeah, hopes, you know.
I don't know if it's anything like this. Just a minute. Yeah,
sometimes it'll be better. So, here are where you've got both key shots,
right there. Uh,
yes. . If you get them, yes, let me just be able to shop
service here. And you can get them where it's more of your journey coming
out. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, So.
Hello. These greats, actually, I'm aware of someone who
can marry your, like, machine video. Yeah.
So just. You give me a smart hand. I'm almost taken.
I wouldn't mess with you again yet. Don't roll. We're going to Okay.
Okay. I'm going do some steps, first and second,
pro quarters, something like that and then, an upgrade course,
you can get a pro then. Yeah.
Uh, we got a picture of the quote from you,
you know, on the smile of the purchase today.
So, so we'll have- Yes, we'll leave us. Thank much.
We'll have the full integration and cleaning and for you to go on to
the status. So you can go on everything.
But that's gonna be where it goes. Go ahead. Good. So, uh,
it was only just to get that in return. Yesterday,
so we can have it as this meeting point today.
But, You Yeah, it's even if even we get ordered today,
my guess is we're not having the IT support at all to get that
help and to get it and everything. I don't know what to do.
So, you know, I feel like we're really just in.
Is that Jessica for you? Um. No,
it's perfect. I mean, me and Helen are so little for us,
I guess. So, when you're at estimate, a big job is who's gonna ask
Nesta? Thanks. No.
Sometimes
a project engineer, when he's doing a changer, is that- I don't even know
where he chops me and be like, yeah, I bet.
I got, like, 30 of these Father's Land or Circles or- I have
this weird profile. Can we see if you have something in your temples so
you can kind of get close and tell the owners play the need to
have. I'm if you're in the place.
I'm not in the type of protest, but I see a price of a
curious model. Ah,
but I'm doing that. Now, there's new day.
I can't even take interest in it. I've got to be an emphasis.
Hey, we have, uh, uh, the, uh, Nestin module that's in,
uh, chat well. I've got, uh, Chindesk, I've got the plates.
Uh, they will not, they'll not,
uh, uh, Nestin, uh, for Nestin.
Don't I guess since we've worked a lot on the stance
of the limited, needless, normal theory thing,
there's a price of a trip that was so long. Uh-uh.
. . . . . No.
No. No.
No. You Now I just do the
ship in a completely different direction here. But I'll talk about the market.
I'll see if there's anything else in it. Thank you.
One of the big takeaways from my A and
C R that we had this week was,
You being able to track our
inspection and rejections,
get those into, one format,
one report, even the new fastball projects,
any rejections, so that they can quantify how to,
you know, areas that the most rejections,
so that we can use that as training towards employees of,
You have the power of many well-projections or government fit rejections,
you really need to button up a Yeah.
That's, umm, that's exactly the part of the SCC guy.
Good. Good. That's why I did come on there.
I didn't want to ever feel anything. I had kind of some NCR
type of feel. You once they had to feel that. Dropped that,
you know, was this on the shooting issue, wasn't a bad computer issue,
wasn't it? What was it, you know? So,
that happened to me- You know, a train, basically a train analysis,
and you know, that's not fair. You put that in a temple somewhere?
Yeah, I didn't see how it was. All the action was- Yeah,
I didn't see ours in the temple,
in the inspections. What did we have? We have a train.
So. I had a inspection.
You wouldn't be one of our, one of our main ones here.
That's my problem. So
are you wanting, uhm,
are you You Or are you just saying,
I have, uhm, I have like the ability to put that extra gear.
So, let's come in, I guess. Yes. That's,
that's what I'm not going to win.
I'd like to see if there's a report we can pull for,
for the reject. Yeah. That option is specifically whether it has to be invented
in each individual project. So I'm going to give you like a,
a roller for the regret. Regents,
yep, so give back in to that. If you're ready to
record, let's go. I love you.
So give it up,
give it up, and then we have good records now here.
Umm, see if we can get your f- where we want it to be,
right? So, uh, it shouldn't be filled with raw data.
So, uh, why would I give you one?
all If you wanted a specific child,
or you just want to, let's just do it across,
yeah. So, let's say, so you get okay. Okay.
Okay. This is all fields that we
can filter based off of, because we've been able to see that.
Bye. And pull over your pass.
And okay, that's what I told. You know,
if you want to see the ones that- Yeah. That's how you
record stuff.
I'm going that. So, you're saying
we call that dad right here?
This is stuff that I would be interested in. They're not a sale,
and they're not starting to give it anything so it's not a sale.
What? What can make this even more?
Water. Helpful is when you have some videos,
like you're, you're talking about names properly,
about why they don't run up. I'll see you in D.F.
has some sort of a drop down deal with that display by the reason
why I type stuff. It makes it much easier.
It's one of the trees. It's they're not really Rovo names to see what's
going on. If I could say, like, how you say it? and in the
next It's, like I said, but it's a machine there or a fabrication there
or it's a finger there or it's a detail there.
Thank you. And then I could be in, I could be in Spark C
and how many detail there is we've had at Puffetas and Shock.
How many machine there is we've had? Yeah. I mean,
faculty issues are more, cause I can feel it a little bit more easy,
rather than having to read all the notes. So,
that's, That's more hope than that. So, like,
for Bitbuck checks, it's like, did I put the clip in the right place?
You'd have an abbreviation for that? Yeah. Yup. Yeah.
Yeah. For the well checks, I imagine you would put all the IP,
you know, in regard to all data, yes,
designation. nation. And there's drop downs.
Yeah. So if you set this,
will this or been? a The part removing,
if they don't fill it out. Not if they don't fill it out.
Now that if you fail it, they- I guess..
There's a- there's a of stuff,
and this is where you can't- you can't make up shit in the- it's
all fine, you know. So you can say that if they fail,
it really couldn't go well because it's not- it's still
the role of the violin. If you go on and it's flying and all
the- all the way to the pan,
and you can- you can't share it, so. I'll one.
You know, say this didn't pass, do you want to keep going, and- and
anybody seems like- yeah. I remember to dissolve it.
Yes. Uh, yeah. There's a preventative,
but not a dead end. and and it's just a taste of it,
but you're looking for more. So we've built it for all
the value of the shakers, all the values for the year that it did.
Good. So,
here's
the card. the enemies today.
Mine, yes, and me. That's,
How does the Tristini activity is? Good. How much can we do that?
You should sit right there with Tom. Yeah,
he has, and Tom is a bee. He's better,
uh, QC diet, essentially. Absolutely.
And the bottom is going to be doing the economy a year ago,
uh, but any show up,
it's not. Uh, they're the first ones that,
Have access to it, and then out of talents for the last two or
three years, and, uh,
before we need the special, actions, and I'm marking these off,
having access to the drawings, to heavily,
only use what, In our drive,
drive box, and, for instance,
the latest revision, I don't even know if I'm bad,
I'm losing surprise. Right here. It hasn't been, um,
the best thing I've ever tried is, uh,
you can go, yeah, uh, use your neck on,
uh, the first person who's- call and,
uh, uh, it was a lot of training at the LME.
So, were at least it, um,
already speaking. Thank you. So,
they used to have a, this,
this trailer that's over here, um,
that used to be really extreme. you be, uh,
ready in between the shop and the place, and,
uhm, they used to have a no key seat trailer,
but, uhm, yeah. You did that,
I saw it out of the way, and it was a small room to
go through that way, and put it in that.
But, here we go. So,
we're be one audience,
and we're going to have about shouts.
So, Midweek on Shout. We used to
have two, uhm, but it has to be able to be both hands and
hands and hands. Bye. I also know that some of the
leads, uhm, the partners' leads will be a little bit better.
I'm going to get tripped this way. Uh, so there I'll set up these
inspectors, and then we'll put their own Canadian columns,
and then we'll put them So, we'll put them So,
we know that it was going in its effect sheets, but I'm going to
look ahead to the rejection reports. Thanks your service.
Shred up, then I think you can see.
It's difficult. I went, I went to the chair,
you know. I mean, I haven't got to say, they do have a drop
in. I mean, I haven't because you know,
that they, you know, like. What they bought because of everyone's without
very often getting changed. Yeah.
Does everybody get a little bit of a shut up? No, I'm sorry.
Thank you much. Well, it's a great video. It's uh,
uhm, they fill that out really
when they pass it. you They have another video that they allow,
which was, here's one of the big things that I mean,
because here's one. Any other topics that I have.
So I. I have to
get to a bit of an extreme.
I was getting a clearer information about that. So if I didn't legislate. you
I was going to get that. So,
yeah, that's cool. You better also go and get some of it.
Yeah. Yep. Yeah. Yeah. And it's interesting.
Share all the goods. Yeah. That's a lot of the issue I had in
my opinion. That was, you know, I saw him in a ski or something.
Okay. I had a lot of news,
but I just said,
uhm, I was recording bass. And then I saw the safety. It's like,
come on. We're not that perfect. And then you're not getting this thing to
do with balance. No, it's part of an issue we're having.
Uh. I'm not sure. The title of the summer is,
uh, let me take a look at it. And Marcus had a hell of
an abandoned house over here. Yeah,
buh. Bye! That's more work for me to do a film and then to
read back and then to the past. And, uh,
I'm not always supposed to hold a new camera.
Okay. I'm not about things being rolled and screwed out.
I'm just, you know, I'm I'm like, I'm screwed up.
I'm like, I'm not screwed up. I'm like, I'll tell you what I'm saying.
I eat. You know, that's it. Okay. Well,
I don't think you see this. It'll circulate.
Not long enough. It'll get fixed.
Thanks. Yeah.
Yeah.
At least it's been fixed on Friday.
You know, it goes very calm and bizarre. We are. Yeah.
And the guy, you know,
he would just flag it. We want visibility,
too. But then, he never put a consistent place to do it.
But if you get by, you know,
this, from, you know, it's a. The whole world is like,
you know, a of a, a little bit of a,
a little bit, a little bit of a.
Alrighty, see a little costume, look, some kind of man out there in their
own, because he, you know, but it's actually,
it's easy. It's a good system, it's a good system.
You . . . Ya, I, I see. Amortz sequence.
Amortz sequence. Oh ya.
What's that? Mis Hey,
I see a lot of this. Yeah, I see a lot of think it's
like, okay. So, the number of what? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah,
that was one of the main things that Mark wanted to cover.
I appreciate this. This kids, it's rather than the one I'm hoping for.
I know it. Uh, um, everything in Will's Bot.
Uh, that was pretty certain, you know,
uh, uh, filter. So that,
that too, but. Good. Good. You know, that people,
uh, get, get off of me and some more gifts.
Actually, for like, even them days, you know.
I love you. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Please leave a goodbye.
I'm making, like, it's a 50% lag,
but I'm using it in advance. Yeah.
Especially with the product. I don't really do it.
Do I? I'm making an advance for status, update,
event, email. I'll send you an entire request now. What two days in purpose
may I say? I'll go second. I believe it. There. Subs www.zeoranger.co I'll send
you an advance so you'll never miss a video.
That's it. See ya. You Now,
the only thing that he might have to do,
too, by the way, is going to take care of it. And that's it,
as you're sticking up and down the wheel.
No. I was the same way I pulled from 2,
3, 4 different Ks to the owner of it.
okay so we can get out and get a little bit
of stuff but, but yeah. Is that really what we're gonna come from the
well said? All right. I know Go ahead and Just, uh,
I would just set a bow in the same process we did just in
the two different inspections for us. So. I'm Uh,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I'll be back to you, which
is sure, uh, St. A, C, S, the most important.
So, it means they actually have to.
That more often than just hit a bit. Okay.
Let's see You Yeah,
I'll move that tongue period if they haven't really passed.
So, That's not.
I mean, you may want to know it's a well-lit drink, lack of pan,
right. I mean, you know, I didn't want to really deal with the cat,
but right on the cat. Yeah. Thank you.
It doesn't
sell you the
alertness of your current undertow, you have to decide.
Okay. Yes, but that would be really nice for that,
OpsGenie, for those three days.
Really good. Thank you. For
those drop-downs, we did it for this car.
. . U Twins, but those were standard air fans?
Umm, they were done staying at station passing,
they were a rest. There's a Catholic bill,
you know, but we want some, somebody in the building,
I suggest, and I've got that said. Thank you very much.
Yeah. Yeah,
I was just, uh, aws,
criteria there. Yeah. You Yeah,
really good working. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. You know. Yeah. Uh.
But I always want to listen to this experience,
and always be fun with the better of the community.
And I'm especially good.
It's too many great here.
Okay. Here we go in 5,000
or so. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah. You got it
now, I'm sure.
Yeah, we didn't have to see our log,
uh, our insulin loss to the smart sheets.
And, uh, the quality of the family,
you know, so you can look at all of that and put it in
the stuff. Um, it's a lot.
Yeah, but we, Uh,
not in the sense of a bit hours, so we'll be in NCR and
say, uh, maybe, uhm,
there's issues. You think it's obvious that these are the property that are connected
to the drug that is connected to the drug. So,
we'll see you in a minute, Mr. March. I'm Yeah,
I also read this picture. Also,
we're needing a copy of this picture.
. . I'm sure, me as well,
and how about this, uh,
and our other engine?
. . . . . . Good. Cheers.
Thank you.
Thank
Each NCR,
so again 55 NCR is in 22,
22. We'll one.
23, 39,
24, 41.
Good one.
So we can do this,
uh, and, uh,
fix it again. He's kind of down to the areas of that.
But, uh, Mhm. So, uh,
it matters. No one else is seeing NCR.
No, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Thanks.
I'm just leave you here. What happens? And they don't freakin' else first.
Yes. I
had some freaking burdens in speed.
So always, very good to see you now.
Get your Thank You know, it's just comfortable.
What is this great about you? Umm, it's just like that.
This is. This is the, uh,
this is the, uh, program that, uh,
most of the, uh, they do all their, their,
their inspections in. Thank But, um,
setbacks, we have all of these non-conformants reports.
I'm not broken out in there, so.
Let's go. I heard it was going to be like that this week,
so I'm going to be able get it done.
Did you guys, could you say it was going to be okay?
Uh, then it's not anything built, man. Thank you. But, uh,
cool, so all of what is getting us from the KTA,
which I've been wanting to replace in it.
It does not have the same level of functionality,
so, uhm, you know, currently you're still about excited about And
then the other area we're hoping to catch from them from what
supports is, uhm. Come on.
Two-pass station, shot-related items.
You take all the single-pig triggers of my equipment.
You may have, not, with only the points, I'm set up.
In there, and, uhm,
hey. So, all of that is documented.
So, then, we're going to attach some of this, which this is going to
be. Bye And, uhm, and, and then,
it's going to be set up together. Okay, and with that,
I use a window that, Yeah, so, uh,
this one, this one while I haven't tried playing with the adding in there.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. But I think this is something that we know,
that I can put in there. We've got a picture in there, and a
table, and the picture isn't that really in the table.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. The last thing I want to do is follow me.
I don't know. I don't know. Okay, we're talking about it,
You know, like, a project in New York and in each section,
you know, you know, like your own. So,
your, your dish could be, You know,
it great because everybody shot this bet,
but your control of the revisions was great because it came down
over any of the waves. You know, when you get drawings on that job,
you're going to pull that section of the manual and only get the latest.
We'll see you week. You know, and I actually,
I don't even start using a thing because it does all the pads,
but I'll be like, okay, alright. Otherwise.
That's actually a good idea. I'm not buying
a singer at someone because I love the distribution.
You should be able to control what, uh,
revision time would be. That's, that's,
that's actually a real good idea.
That's it. And if,
if, if nobody is looking to build up some flair in it,
then we'll be able to get it to quality really.
So. . . Ehm,
I and we do have some time to support anything for a shop beggar,
a shop , . I'm not sure I'm willing to get following any of
this. I can be a family that's because of the personal person,
the son of this bag. Yeah. And then, eh, eh, ehm,
ehm, it was easily accessible on the second.
Yeah. Go grab your, your cheese and bottle.
Thank you. Be pretty hopeful.
But yeah, that sometimes,
or there's a fairly key to the body control as the legs,
and I don't know. So, uh,
we've only got one fail, and we've only got two passes,
and then you go. . Yeah,
I have more,
umm.
. . . Hispanic, uh,
Inspector, that didn't not fail, they said it has.
Oh, boy, come on.
Oh, dude. Yeah, yeah, Hey,
hey, what's up? It's not any .
. that's your job. Yeah, because that .
. that's right. You . .
. Yeah, well, happy jobs.
Alright. Hit
it in a cone 3D team to go home. No. With,
uhm, shipping guys, as we would see that experience,
mine.org. So,
uhm, it's to her, keeping that up pretty well.
So, I go through it a little bit. Two more times,
the biggest issue in the internet can be developed with it.
Stay safe. We'll be here. Uh,
you're out there and you're gonna throw it back in.
So, I'm standing on the yard. Couldn't be long.
Didn't you say that last time. Ooh. . . And then,
uh, second walk back in here is a quick video.
Unaductant. Well, it's like seem to work out- I'm not one,
but, are there any,
uh, access points that are from H here that I'll- I
mean, you're here, Phil. Um, uhm,
it's out of bias. Uh,
yeah, it's out here. There. Uh, but we have a fair octave line here.
It's good. I was in the center of the yard at the best center
of the two shops, and it was, it was pointless there.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm getting ready just barely scraping,
and then, and then, as we bark further out,
cause I'm pretty sure we all. . We also have one big corner by
our glass theory, and so we have a whole little So
I think by the way, we need to extend the raise on those.
Umm, the other thing here, you know, IT is getting a dedicated solid.
I love Right out there, because we're already operating
and starting anyways. So, um, yeah. Umm, here's where we're going.
If you can, if you if I know you're a champion,
you shouldn't be able to have one later,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Bye! Bye!
Got it. I actually, for a while, I had a,
uhm, it was a really cheap one, but it was,
uhm, this, it was- built for usage on farms,
from where you could have a life. I, I have some that it would
be one literally set in Turkey. Thank you.
You can, uh, wildlife for a mile,
if you can see straight. It's very,
it's very cheap. Uh.
Oh. But, from the Parks League lawyers,
I actually really did. That's what you know about the system,
really. We changed. I mentioned that, you know,
Board of Stays, but I had no trouble in it, but,
yeah, I think it's something, and your opinion is gonna happen,
I can help the Saudi at that point. Oh, no. Over Oh. But,
yeah, any centering? Yeah,
I think I'm an exterior one,
and I'm like, well, we should be able to, uh, open the rocks. We
will see you week. Right, anyways. Yeah,
that's one, uh, that's one issue that you have here with Vast.
It's a lot better than the first part. it to . . Yeah, it
has to be for Vast. Can you see it right?
I need you to put 200 in the place to set you down and
share it by some kind of problem. Yeah.
Wow. Terrible. Now I've written one over a thousand.
And, uh, as long as you get to set me on it.
... ... ... That's great. Simple. You get good.
We're getting worse, for piano solo, uh-uh, yeah.
We need to keep going the work well.
All right. It's out there. Of course it's like,
I'm good at the even more of this out there.
But, yeah. There go.
It's always better out there.
Do it out there. Yeah. Like I said,
I got a new string file and a heap number difference.
We'll see in a second. All the time. Some of the people are working
to that. Some of us are actually on a heap number two.
Yeah, that one we got this one. morning. So, hey,
I should not play a couple of dudes' paperwork.
So, very, very confusing.
Thank So, I mean, that's,
like, two by nine, that was in a meeting that was down below,
for all of them, and to be there above.
Love. And, guys, if there's no heat coming from this thing,
there is truly no heat coming from this fight off of the other other
truck. Yeah. Thank you, Jira.
All Well, actually, we've done it to you.
Oh, okay. But, you guys, that's right. I think you figured it out.
You guys, it's so mean, documented all the heat numbers. That's going to We'll
see you Bye. I'm not going to steal it. So,
that'll, that'll make it stick with it.
Yeah. So. Oh. Is that what you let go of?
Is right, is right, is right, is is Everything is a heat number,
a heat number, a number, a heat number, a heat number, a heat number.
And then the purchase for their number.
So, yeah, it's, it gets,
since I've already gotten them, we're just, are really deep.
Thank Unique, you can go.
So, we got the easy number, uhm, get our internal development and then
the purchase. Thank your support. So, uhm,
so, uhm, if we go to new purchase markets,
some of these new channels. our beliefs.
uh, uhm,
this one. Okay, that's the purchase order and we're getting an easy number again.
Okay. Okay. But going to do just so.
In reference to the line information right on top of the bit and then
as the operators are.
Now it's the same songs, they're cutting off the heat number,
so I have to reach for this information better at it,
uh, peace. Thanks. So much,
seems to be worth it a while. Yeah, I've had too many issues,
I used to be hearing this. this. A Douglas I have some very
good memories of the red tangy of the majority of us in New York.
Yeah. That's what I'm going to want everyone to be honest is,
yeah, what's going on here? So, hmm. That's, that's.
Next slide.
It is something comes, uhm,
yeah, I think it's true to, uh,
pretty quickly if you have a good idea. I don't So,
uhm, yeah, I think it's really good to see you on a good trip.
Please, and I think it's, uhm, a Just say it.
I think it's really good to see you I think it's really
see you good trip. See me from this,
like, integration of the electrical materials that's,
uh, that's from top of it. Good news.
You have memories of your big
fans over the installation.
Okay. You just pull up the sheet and working over.
Okay.
People.
You
Alright.
Nope. I'll see you in the video.
in the church
is about how we got this pretty well,
you know. We got back with the
idiot. Please. Good news. I mean,
it means you got back with the idiot. You have a good issue with
the idiot, but please, it means that's not an apartment.
That was the bus. You have a
bus move. Ah, I don't know if people will try to think you're at
one passage. You don't have any father or mother,
whether they're you're good for the one, not one to do it.
Yeah, I'm willing to see you, uhm,
as we said over in the second area. . . Yeah, uhm,
then I'll move from this one and give them a shot and see if
I can, I'll leave that as a, uhm, uhm, hmmm.
and I'll, even if it's just clean it up and then add it to
a part of our procedure that, uh, uhm, uhm, uhm,
of each week. Thanks. Just close out our videos,
you know, just being a Friday task force.
I don't really want to know in monthly. Please. Because,
some months ago, I have a hundred people,
purchase orders, so someone's moved out of 12.
So, why haven't took a day before- I can't really see you,
I'm already at the end of the week. It's definitely you, or,
umm, anyone that receives all storage- So going In the
chat forums. So I don't know if it's a bit of a shoot that
you're receiving. Oh, that's you, but you only receive Bitbucket once after- That was
the interesting. Now,
I'm not on the site and reference back to it,
and I'm not a customer who's requesting the birth of material received.
See you. For payment, uhh,
a couple of our customers will do that,
but there's a payment, put it in the token.
. Yeah, it's the same, we're going to be able to do it in
here, and we're going to do it in T.R.
and MediRoute. Where are some of us are messed up?
See ya. Yeah, look from the desk outside.
So that is a little receiving in the yard.
Please don't see anything else in the box.
All scans in, all of the,
uh, receivers, yeah, pulls in the TRs from,
uh, physically back to the MTRs.
. In the TRs, the pull of a seat for that A into the
full B. What we're afraid of, you have found a lot of that.
I don't believe it. You can do all that,
and that's kind of the feeling of the field.
We've received it. We've asked them to be ours.
I think so. But. I haven't yet since finalized in the process.
You really can't doubt me. It's our correct question.
So today, right, but otherwise your system gets all
in zero quantities. System about it.
Do it. A lot of people use it. For some,
maybe, you know, like,
uhm, the reason I asked, you got to pay for it back is,
if you found one. I what it's back for you. You ever saw a
little thing that wasn't on us, and I asked him,
or she, you may be able to pay for it back in you.
Yeah, uhm. Bye. I just think we're leaving some sort of something over the
weekend, so. But yeah,
yeah, everything good. I'd be able to see these in the process.
Nah, I definitely would not be close to us.
Yeah, cause I don't know if we were able to catch them beyond this.
I mean, it's just been two more- clips.
So, yeah, the only thing that's starting to see that we're going to need
to, uhm.
So, I'm pulling the lathe and putting this people forward,
and then lining up a job,
uhm, from my process plate.
Ready? So, uhm, in orders on Tuesdays and
Thursdays every week.
But you can follow us in front of it.
Why not? Yeah. So, if you get- if maybe you follow us in front
in front of us when we do that, I'll leave you soon.
If you a receipt, you would be following us. Shouldn't I get it?
Another ship? And next week, you follow us.
It's really hard to do the following us. There are other dragons in here.
Good. Good. Keep it in and out the process is forward to it all.
This panel can be a revitalized line by line.
So, yeah. Good. Good. Nah,
that was stupid. Yeah. Thank you.
Or,
like, I said, you can figure out that, ah, ah,
keep it, you said it, do it. And we'll see you next once a
week or something, but, yeah. I think they've
got a, they've got they've got an option.
Thank you, everyone. I'm like, I don't know about the biggest process.
That sort of is no importance. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, in an iterative, that side is pushed as
for the, You know, you can make it against things that say, I never
had to do it. Later, I had to do it.
That's, it's a big while, I'm not doing it.
I'll back I'm just
going to do it.
I'm just going to do it. Bye-bye. I didn't necessarily add anything,
uhh, with a quick ending that we have there,
but that's kind of something that- I'm gonna do anything,
estimate by estimate basis, yup.
We're gonna do just some of this, which is pretty great. Have evening.
Have a good All right. Here's your Bye. Let's go. We're gonna do, umm,
the semi-retic presence is the main portly.
Yeah. Pretty pretty. So,
um. Go. Go. That's,
that's, uh, always along with anybody. There's always very similar reason to create one.
Alright. That's, that's,
that's it. Nice guys, gorgeous. This, You know,
we didn't have to face any of that,
but the main,
the main, The reason that was on here is because they
wanted face coats in here,
time and time. You very wants to experience this,
uh, and that's not, that's not, that's not,
that's not, that's not, that's not, that's not.
Love you. I'm assuming you do ask that.
It's not about you, it's the end.
So, okay, I think it says that I broke it out by these pairs.
those. So, let me put it in this,
right? If you put it, if you put it in 10,
the template just gives you that break. No,
I guess. . You know, you can start, and you can only do it
pulling out like, all that panic.
You can just do it, too.
You will be here. The other part of it is, uhm, these animals have
a really, really big job as to who tends to hate, uhm. Go ahead.
Go ahead. Each area, of course,
and then we did ready to comment station for,
uh, maybe a little bit of all being free.
99, 1000, forward,
dock, river, but in each area within 39,
1001, 300 times in 2,
300. Good. It's just gonna throw
up 3001,000.
. Yeah, but it would give you,
it would give you a shot.
You would have to, right?
And then you could, so,
the three non-1000,
one, are you, are you fine? I'm sure you can have them if you're
on your best limits right now so that you can,
if you're having to split it out by that.
So, essentially, my- I mean,
if you're better than one of the estimate, for example, labor,
yeah, the biggest thing in a lot of times, uhh,
well. If I can pull uhh,
this was a job for the biggest animal.
on board.
Uhh.
So, like, this one is heavy and missing.
It's not also both skills. It's so many different styles.
So. It's not the same style of the mission.
No, not. So, like, they have ladders broken,
especially with the United States, broken. So,
they, they, uhm, stay at the dock.
That was one of those, the dock got from a red sheet.
Retaining walls, retaining walls of red sheets.
. So, each of these different breakouts will cast a different
code associated with it. Yes,
each of you. These have their own, their own neighborhood budget.
So, right. When they break it out,
they keep those, they keep it separate.
I'm sure.
So, you are having to be able to break that out. Yeah. So, if,
If the goal is to keep everything in 10,
then you need to break that out with the intent.
Good. So, you know, the Thanksgiving,
the Thanksgiving's here and there, the costumes,
they, uh, at the end of the day.
So, if you get a break, like, break that allowance,
even being what the face can do is the rest of the house.
It's a good place to do it, I'm glad you're very glad you're not
in front of this place. So, I'm a partnership with Ian.
Okay, Ian. Uhm, Bismarck. And so, Ian,
with Ian Jackbud. you You know, it's very expensive.
It's, it's, it's cost. Oh, yeah, I'm okay to take it.
Now, so I'm going to want it to save. So, I'm having to use
all of this. So, you can, you can, you can,
you can either always. Thank much.
Thank you so much. You are welcome. You can do that right,
or you can do a lot, a lot,
a lot of bases inside. This one.
The other line is this costume. And when you do that,
that thing, once you finish, you're asking that,
you, you can just, Thanks watching! It's like,
sure about this, but, uhm, when I post it,
it'll give you the breakdown of that, so,
The other story, you gotta know that, right? I'm gonna go.
So, if anything would kinda make sense to set it up in there,
if we're going to say we're gonna take every day in the order- I'm
gonna wrap it up with a pet.
Yeah, let's do it. Yeah. Okay. And
that's, uh, in many minutes and in past many minutes.
Thank you Yeah,
in past few minutes. Thank you very much.
So that's where you would send it up and possibly the universal area within
estimating the site. Okay,
this cost. Hello. The cost code pertains to this particular labor,
or material, or galvanizing,
or like. Okay, bye.
I agree Thank you.
So
it's all condensed- Thank you. Yeah, it's going to be your shot in half.
Yeah.
That's uh,
Okay.
So you live in that costume.
I don't know if it's the only one thing. But,
I should be living in . Okay,
you're good. Okay.
Thank you. Okay.
Good morning. Thank you. Okay.
to do.
and
here I have a- Yes, I'm not going to do this,
dude. I wouldn't be put back
in my category, son. I'm not going do this Hey,
you sure didn't even feel that you're not going to do this,
you know. Cause, uh, I'm not quite sure.
You're not going to have to be able to break out in the twenty
twenty-six. Are you going to make things out?
Yeah. But I think they're doing it by- I think they're going categories,
so category page, page category.
I think they're going to be able to break out by all the- I
don't know if they're accustomed to, but,
I mean, that- since it's not literally going to be able to pull over
in this way anyway. You're just going to never afford to put
it in this, uhh, engagement with OpsGenie,
uuuh. Here we go. You Okay,
and that might be part of why the union is also
part of the union, honestly. Totally.
you I'm killing pro-bore. Yeah,
just pro-bore. Um, like, I mean, this is, is. I this.
I hope that you can explore where that's the good thing you see to
do. Except, yup. And, uh, this, this is also a cloud.
All'all.
All right. We're getting more new business.
So, they'll re-map it and pay a sense for being used this
for- Or, I'm going to have a second page,
and then add a Facebook line item in,
and then these. issues. 7 Same thing there, yep,
that same thing there, yep.
I
can see you too, bye. I am. I don't anything,
uh, okay, so I don't see anything, uh, far forward,
excavated while I stay. Thanks for being here.
I will. Hey. You do get a little tech club,
so that's the fact of which you can get rid of.
Uhh.
Perfect, thank you, help. Good to hear anything.
Okay.
Other
than the costage you can trade with oil. Go. If you need to continue,
I think there's a cost time to deal with this, uh, uhm. We'll do.
All right. Yeah. All right. We'll do that. Oh,
we're done. you
So
now, wait for me to check and see what the projects can seriously- You
can use on a great position
later. I've wondered- I don't know if this- This is one of those movies
where you get- get supplements and say, hey, yeah,
some are you. How about that?
I'm going to go around to my position.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
You guys have a commodity
pricing matrix that you updated online.
Bye bye. Still related,
you know. Uhh,
I'm just a lot of personal history, basically. Please. Yeah,
so what we did is, in the comments,
I just had, and everything.
I'm not a procurement guy, I just send it out,
and this isn't a price for that, and for our custom-making purposes,
we never can laugh until it's for a p********** knowledge, so.
Oh, yeah? Yeah. Yeah, it means by,
you know, a 36, a past 16,
17, we have more than one six. Thanks. Y'all,
the time you go out is if you're quoting a truck loan or something
really big and you can get it for one plate here and one plate
there. Now, for those,
uhm, for those most of the time you'll reach out to the leading truck
person, Mr. Ryu. You It's been purchased for a while,
because of the two. It's always had a perceived increase of the owners
of that environment. Have you seen this? I mean,
it's nice that you can dump that off on quote unquote,
the concurrency that they just are responsible for keeping
that up. Yeah, we should work.
It's always something we can put together. I like some of our vendors,
so you don't have to apologize today. You can go on to the website,
or you can just re-sign back up with pro developers and re-establishing
online. Yep. Okay, we'll see next Is they all, uh,
associated with my whole team and all that,
but you're right. I had all the next sense of all of them.
Yeah, so I'm working for me established online.
That's,
uh, depending on it,
I mean, there's always one bit, and I'll be scared.
Thank you. Close. Especially when you're doing better stuff.
Yeah, and I'm usually, because I'm an estimate,
I would run weekly. you I would take a look to see what the
price of things was doing.
Ah, I'd say, hey, uh, next month is, Service Chairs Are Changing. Well, that's
probably the scene. I don't I don't But I don't It's all published,
Jira. Yeah. Yeah,
it's all accessible, something that will be deep.
But, you know, uuh,
I'm going to wait until the shipment plays.
What's your part? Anytime soon,
come out and share. Yes.
Bye. Bye.
It's Good.
Thank
you, man. Good night. Good night.
Yeah. You That's a venue.
Yep. Feel free to get more. Yep. Yeah.
Yeah. You know, it's in your contact holiday.
Where? So, when you stall it in life for this meeting,
yep. He's in there, you know,
so if you touch him, then we put him in the contacts.
And only, you don't have his phone in the picture. It's in there.
. No. Because I gotta reveal all that,
all that stuff. It's, I mean, it tastes very good.
Yeah, yeah. There go. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank
you. Thank you. Having them all submitted for
once here, the work related one,
hang on. Alright. Alright. That's a bit of a,
a bit of a list, a paper and a flat paper,
a bit of a 12-gang of things, I basically put it on a little
bit later. I'm falling. I was prepared now because they came and bought me
on my computer one morning, but about a public.
Well, good. I the floor of it,
kind of backed up by contacts and my other contacts.
I set it to my, to see if there's a file.
I'll see you later on to myself. There were some other
things that I wanted. I just,
The keys instead. Here,
now. I've been to places that have done that and made the places in
it. Yeah, later. How late do you like it?
Everything. One place you need to find out if you can make it with
a bus. No, that's right. And normally when you get a notice,
you're not that good. Sure. I was a construction manager,
so they actually kept me from, like, doing that in three weeks.
But the day it came, it's okay. Okay. Stand up,
walk with your keyboard, don't touch anything,
and here's the box. You know,
I'm gonna turn it and notice the depth. That's it. Yeah. All right. Okay,
but, that's why I'm so big.
Yeah. So, I'm gonna turn
it again. You need your badge? Yep. Yep.
I have to make this off at home from order.
you ha ha ha The 903
low 4-2. 4-2.
Check. Ultimately,
it's- A little bit of a,
surviving, in touch. It'd be slow than a hundred there,
wouldn't be any use. Ok. Bye. Good.
Good. Kind of long as it was,
I think it was sweet, it's more unusual behind that side.
What we need, anymore, need that word. And right there,
well that line where it won't, there's going to be sweet,
there's going to be sweet, there's Oh,
yeah. You cannot believe it. Anyone agrees with their tips on it?
Yeah. That's just all that's great about the developing
program. You I don't know where it's going. I don't know where going
to uhh.
Well,
we should not get it.
He's divided in units.
Do you know how I'm going to play a role very much? I'm just
going to go up there. We're going to do I don't know.
Like what? I need to do it. Alright, some one does not work.
Ehm. That's the deal.
That's good stuff. There's a heat check there. What do you think
about that as well? You Yeah, I see,
so, we got some really good
welded. Good. So,
Netflix and guys can understand. We'll take it down,
uhm,
even like, remote. Oh uhm, in case one of the days I was there.
Cause I had a structural experience and I had a lot of video experience.
Just come back. So, he's a very good,
uh, he's very good at doing this.
So, and the advice is here, so I'll be good at losing.
The one where he is in his performance. So.
I don't know why, but I was like, wow, I can't because of the
actual himself. So, I mean, it's, it's still bad.
It's still bad. And it's, it's almost back on.
Bye And I have a lot of that still bad.
That's very important to me.
So, you all, well, okay. You don't have any money for it.
I don't know if you've paid it just well for living in the book.
Uh, you lost all my best, but, yeah,
stop that. It's a huge win. All right,
good. I-I don't miss a layoff,
but it's just-they're eating all the water,
leaving them in the chat.
So, yeah. Thank you. Yeah, and they have a background.
Alright.
This is one week,
and, uh, four of you. This is the next week.
I hope you put it. So, uhm. On
that. So.
Yeah. So we ended up.
So, I don't want you to deliver it,
because they're in a dog. We're going to go sit down and see if
we're going to have time for that. So we're going to go ahead.
Bye. And I'm going to be attached on a bit of a shoot here.
It's not going to be right. And I'm going to sit down and see
if I can. I can get, you get it to get me.
That was said, I'm going to do a little bit of a burnout.
Do you know where the PQR? four. Yes, I'm going to do of
a burnout. You Oh,
okay, okay. Thank you.
Teakout, Judy,
Matt on the other shoulder. Under that,
it's the original Rovo.
So, maybe there's an use
of winging. Thank you.
Thanks
for asking what we really had about the shipping team.
Thank you. Thank you.
I'm not
going to say that. I'm not going to say You Oh,
shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
What did that one do? And I never heard of anything.
. . .
. . And that's what I'm going to do.
So, thank you.
I feel like I'm going to add a little bit more lately,
you know. I mean, it's all about kicking with more.
Oh I'm going to change that. So I'm going to do like that as
much as I'm sure. So the match,
I'm going to do anything. Ah. Bye-bye.
This is a big question. There was one guy out of this doing it
in the line. It's not going to be in the fire, it's going to
be in the middle. And then it comes from here. D. D.
D. D'Ratt Let it Got it Along.
And as you've heard it, you to be in st Coby now.
Ourshine, YuuYuLil . So basically our,
as you know, call here, Jay McPhee,
Gilbert, to J.R.S.
For everything you took company through,
yeah, during the pandemic. Part of the pandemic was original,
gee. All right. Anybody who's more overwhelmed as that.
We'll see you
in a minute. So you're right.
As I see, you are part of the KV draw.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you for the,
the evidence in Jira, Midi. We're excited for it in this.
Yeah. Yeah. Hey Hey Hey ya.
I'm gonna be glad there's a,
uhm,
a half. Got it. Now that's our. Yeah. So,
I'm gonna be going to turn up a little bit.
Right. Let's have a little bit of a move. in five years old.
It's a super-spy.
It's not good. Ah, it's just good.
What's your name? Good. One of the years I've been able to be great.
I've been begging, I've been begging, and so I haven't clogged enough yet.
That's good. Well, I'm sure you'll be better. So, go. . . . See
ya. Thank you.
It's like we're wrapped up,
right? Yeah, I think I'm gonna head out to the bottom and take some.
So, Well,
good to meet you. Yeah, you too. Thank you for your time.
Wish that fun day too, that one is so brutal.
We're done. Ha, ha ha ha. Have us just horrible tableds.
Yep. Have you ever heard that person's fast?
Cause you may their call? Oh. Yeah. Let's see you.
Yeah. For you right here. Alright. Sounds good.
Yeah. That was all good. It's all good. So. Good.
Good. Alright. If you guys hit the other,
I'll see you in a minute. If you want to cross stuff,
you need me for something screaming. But